sigh I'm so busy I didn't get this I didn't start exactly at
five but Doki where's Doki every time I don't start exactly
at five where's Doki is she napping where is she oh my god
she's late I'm so sorry guys that I started 40 seconds after
five oh my what a sin how could she how could doki do this
to us starting 40 seconds after five she fucking haters us
she hates us dragoons shake my head thank you for the time
give me the chips thank you thank you betrayed how could she
oh my god anyway guys i'm sorry i didn't start at exactly at
five um i actually had like my my sense of time uh got got
got in the way because like i was working on like three
different projects simultaneously in the last like hour so i
was And I was like, oh, and I was like, okay, it's 450.
Surely I can work an additional nine more minutes before I
start stream.
I was like, and I was like, oh, shit.
I didn't even pull up any of my applications.
I didn't boot up the game or anything in the last minute.
All right, it's 459.
I can boot up everything in one minute.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
There's so many things.
And I have to pack it.
Oh my gosh, yesterday, I've been so busy yesterday, yes,
okay, so we have 60, recently, I don't know when I tweeted
this, but recently we received 60 giant packages of, like,
of debut dokeybird merch.
So 60 boxes, there's like barely space in my tiny apartment
right now.
So like, the lobby people called us and was like, hey.
we received a lot of packages and i was just like huh and i
was like oh shit and like it came in with like 30 so like 30
first and then and then like um and then more like 30 more
came and i was just like like i was just like oh my god
they're sick i did not i okay look we were told i ordered
we're told it was 60 boxes and we're told I was told 60
boxes but I couldn't comprehend how many 60 was I couldn't I
couldn't comprehend how many 60 boxes actually was because I
was like oh that's not that much right because I lost my
sense of like how many people is alive so so I was like
Like, ah, 60 is not that bad.
And then boxes kept coming into my apartment more and more
and more.
And I was just like, so I don't have a hallway anymore.
Um, and like, it's so bad that like, you know, where the,
when you walk in the pathway where the boxes are, there's
like barely light.
there is there is barely any light when you start walking
through the hallway because the boxes just tower above you
and uh so i've been like slowly packaging them myself
yesterday so i like package like two yes okay i package two
because i have to organize the inventory and stuff like that
um you guys must be wondering why are you packaging them
yourself good question mom why am i packaging them so anyway
i'm slowly sorting and sorting it out with myself at the
moment anyway I hope to like I hope we can start shipping
them shipping them out uh next week well it's gonna be
slowly I'm so sorry if it's gonna be like if there is a
delay in the end I am so sorry I'll try to be more
transparent about it if there is gonna be a delay going
forward but I'm trying my best to like start uh to like uh
package them and sending them out bundles might take a bit
longer uh to do um because i don't think i ordered enough
packaging materials for for the bundles so i've like i
recently ordered more envelopes and stuff like that uh for
the for all the merch and uh and um but i can start shipping
the smaller stuff like the people who order the smaller
things because i have enough of that of that but like for
the bundles and stuff it there might there might be a little
delay for the bundles just a little bit i hope but if it
does end up being a longer delay i'll try to be transparent
with you guys i'll give you guys updates about it so time to
rent i thought i had a warehouse i like gate okay like
that's why i was like i'm gonna start like being more on top
of things because i was so busy of the stuff uh to my
parents because they said they wanted to work on that for me
and then so I thought I had a warehouse until I got 60
packages sent to my apartment and I was like where's the
distributor I was like I thought this is gonna be sent to a
distributor and then and then i was like so so i was like i
guess i'm the warehouse now i don't know what's going on
that's why i don't know what's going on at the moment but i
don't want to be like late with orders um so yeah my
apartment's the distributor my apartment's the warehouse for
now So like I'm trying to be like on top of like there's a
lot of things going on So like I'm trying to be like super
on top not like okay I can't say I'm on top of everything
when my apartment is literally the warehouse right
But it's been pretty rough because like I'm doing like
hundreds of jobs at once every day And I'm hoping that next
week when I have my actual break break that like everything
is um everything is like uh i guess like settled or like
finally organized um and like i'm actually looking i'm
currently also okay i'm like doing so many things i'm
actually currently looking for a place for myself like to
live on my own technically like i used to live on my own and
then like uh and then my parents started living with me i
paid for and everything by the way so it's not like you know
i'm living like at my parents place my parents are living
with me um but like i'm to like starting yesterday i've been
like actually looking for a place for myself to be more like
um independent and then i guess like use my part my other
this apartment as a warehouse i guess because and like i
will have to pay like two rents but that's I'm thankful for
you dragoons for like supporting me so that I can afford to
pay technically like if I When I do get my new place, I'll
be paying for two rents.
I'm not buying a place because like in Despite the amount of
support you guys have given me like the housing the house
The real estate the real estate market in Canada is fucking
terrible.
So
so so this but yeah in this economy like you guys support me
so much but like in this economy in the housing market like
i'm not gonna be buying a place anytime soon next you thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you uh power you
don't get hope living on your own goes well thank you thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you thank you thanks
for playing the game that had the most amount of hours
played in my entire library weighing over 2000 okay to be
fair that's never that's not as much as my dad he's been
playing this game for like two for like two to three years
non-stop every day so like since it got launched sometimes
he goes back to it like ever so often so like the intro of
fallout 4 is like fucking ingrained in my head because i've
seen him replay the intro he created numerous characters um
multiple I feel like every time I see him play Fallout 4,
it's a new character, so like I fucking know the intro by
heart.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, let's say this to the
docast, but yeah the housing market.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you.
But yeah, I am really, I, oh my gosh, I haven't like looked
for my own place for so long.
I think for like I think like for a very long time since I
guess like since you know since like Oh my gosh, I don't
remember I have like usually like um I don't have to look
for myself uh, but like I don't even know if I hope like I
hope like my my future landlords if I see a place and I
don't have to compete with like 50 other people like i'm
pretty sure i'm gonna have to compete with 50 plus other
people and then like i i feel like if they find out i have a
dog they'll be like no the hardest part is finding a pet
friendly apartment to rent as well and that's like the
hardest part because usually landlords would be like no pet
the bet like the better the bet the bet the better you are
as in like you know pets quiet
uh good credit uh no noise complaints oh fuck i need to find
a place that has like that has good that has thick wall i i
know that like some places they'll be like um if you they'll
have like 50 plus uh people applicants they'll have 50 plus
applicants and then and then they'll choose the one with
zero no pets uh not you know i guess like sometimes they
prefer university students because they are like university
students that study and like no they won't party or anything
because like that was me i remember like as a university
student I was like the go-to client like the go-to applicant
I was basically the dream applicant the dream tenant for so
many landlords like every time I applied for like a place
because at that time I didn't have like Doki Amber Doge so
like they'll be like oh my god she has no pets she's by
herself she's alone
she obviously only studies like look at her she doesn't
party
and and she's just she's she seems like a like a good person
so every time i remember in the past i would apply for a
place i'll be like i instantly get it like i don't think
i've ever been rejected for a place just because in
university i was like a university student and but like i
had like all the good traits of a university student like
and like i was able to afford um like a decent place i guess
like quote unquote decent place for like a single person so
like so then they'll like oh and by back then i didn't
stream as well so there was zero noise complaints i i also
did not stream so i had zero noise complaints so they're
like geez perfect i remember one time i like try to i i
actually like i was actually looking at several places and
had several landlords trying to compete for me as a tenant
it's that is that fucking crazy like like one was like um a
basement like what was it called like a basement suite so
like there was a family that was living you know the family
was renting out their their basement suite and the other one
was an apartment and um and then like obviously i'm sorry to
the family to the family in the i'm sorry to the family in
the basement suite but i rejected the basement suite because
like like there was a They had a little baby.
They had a baby.
And I was like, oh no.
Will that be considered like a free babysitter for them in
the future?
They were in like the suburbia.
They were in suburbia too.
So I was just like, oh no.
I have to walk to the bus stop.
Instead of like going.
like I have to walk several blocks to get to the bus stop to
like get to my university but like you know the other one
the bus stop was like you know it was at an apartment at a
decent place so it was like I just have to walk like maybe
like three minutes to the bus stop to get to my university
so I was like no I'm sorry but then like the app the
landlord for the basement suite they like sent me like
several emails to convince me They sent me like several
emails to like convince me to choose them as like their lad
like to choose them to write.
They're like we think you're the perfect tenant.
Like how's the application going?
Cause like they're like, oh we need like it's just like it's
the rules you need to fill out this application and stuff
like that.
And they sent me like like two email two to three emails
being like oh what do you think like we really think you're
the perfect tenant for us like we really want you to rent
our place like oh how's the how's the application going on i
felt so sad i was like oh i'm sorry i found another place
that like suits me better even the and then the apartment
tenant also was like oh we think you're the perfect tent
like i literally just did like one i just went to one um i
went to like one like you know where you have to like look
around the apartment and then just like talk like just talk
to them and just be like what your thoughts are and stuff
and after that they'll be like uh after that they'll be like
oh i think you're per like i think we will uh i think like
the apartment guy was like right after the interview and
like looking around the apartment they were like oh yeah
like we think we want you to be the tenant like the open
house yeah yeah yeah the open house because like they like
right after the open house they were like oh yeah yeah we
want you to be our tenant like yeah we're not gonna look at
the other other applicants anymore and i was like oh okay
yeah i think this is a good place make them it's gonna make
them funny i think it's also because like i've you know how
okay so um i'm like the ideal tenant because like The reason
why I'm the ideal tenant is because like I write my checks
in advance.
So basically like I just give them like six months of checks
in advance and be like, so I don't have to keep up with it.
So I don't, I don't.
So I just be like, okay, like, like you don't have to chase
me for rent.
I was just like, I was just, like I pays on time doesn't
party like just doesn't did stream at that time so I had no
noise complaints um and then I'll just be like okay here's
like here's some checks in advance so like you know I'm
pretty I hope I have the money by then but like I know I
don't see like I think I have the money by then when you
deposit these checks every month but you don't have to pay
you don't have to chase me in advance like
okay anyway but yeah so so i hope that's the same because
it's different now it's different now i have a dog so i have
a dog i i stream so there's gonna be noise complaints maybe
and it's like I'm just like oh man and it's so people people
don't fucking buy houses here We all fucking rent because
the housing market is fucking terrible in Canada I don't
know how it can get worse, but it did I remember five years
ago.
I was like how can this get worse and then it still gets
worse Like it's still buying houses can still go up Did we
not learn anything from the first financial crisis?
Like did we not learn anything from?
the first housing crash i don't know but it's back up again
um yeah and anyway and anyway i hope i'm still the ideal
tenant because like i've been like looking around for places
to like to see like where i could rent it's so hard it's so
difficult because like i i have like so many other factors
now that i i'm like a streamer like a content have a fucking
pet so there's so many factors to look into now when it
comes to like uh when it comes to finding a place because
finding a pet friendly place is so difficult it's so fucking
difficult anyway anyway everybody sorry for the 23 minute
tangent guys but let's play the game up for it's time i'm
super excited to try out fall out for i never played fall
out for uh my i never whoa sorry the game was like went
crazy on my it's definitely not 244 hertz because the game
started like adjusting my hertz and stuff and was like this
is not it
well i tab if i tab i would have fuck with my okay it didn't
i was gonna say what it like it like the monitor like
flickered and so oh you saw that flicker yeah
oh please don't oh my gosh where's my cursor where did my
cursor where's the cursor
Wait, where is the cursor?
Where is it?
Wait, okay.
I see my cursor on the other monitor.
Ooh, okay, give me a sec, guys.
I gotta figure out where my cursor went.
Oh, Bethesda.
Bethesda, Bethesda.
Alright, guys, let me restart the game.
I don't know where my cursor went.
I was like, where did it go?
It just works.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Alright, play.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Part 6, what makes you special?
What makes me special?
Whoa!
That's a nuclear bomb.
Total atomic
uneducational materials for you to better understand.
I don't have a controller plugged in.
What do you mean?
Agility!
A nuclear blast and the subsequent fallout will have many
adverse effects on life as we know it.
Intensive prolonged radiation exposure may transform into
decrepit rotting beings that have lost their ability to
reason i bet someone would still want to bang that though
not me of course not me
yeah me straps
yeah me especially after this show oh somebody here really
liked the ghoul can also help you out in difficult whoa who
needs agility if I go all attack I don't need agility if I
shoot the head okay we're never doing stealth by the way
guys into a complete tactical move keep in mind exactly no
need to dodge if they're dead
Your agility will help you move through the wasteland with
ease and yield other benefits like assaulting an
unsuspecting dreamer for the in hastily reloading your fire.
What?
By piling on damage to additional targets when the regularly
study your vault tech provided materials to prepare for
survival.
Them.
And to answer the question, do you know what makes you
special?
I do!
Because I'm anime.
Alright, there you go.
Where's my cursor?
What the fuck?
I did all of that!
Where the fuck's my cursor?
Okay, I'm gonna plug in my controller and see if it finds my
cursor.
I can't.
Where the fuck's my cursor?
I can't believe it.
I watched all that and my cursor still didn't fucking show
up.
I am pressing enter chat.
I pressed enter.
Sorry, another flicker.
Guys, I'm pressing space and enter.
I don't understand.
Oh my god, it just works.
It just works.
Okay, guys, give me a sec.
I'm gonna Google this.
Where is my cursor?
It fall out for.
Okay, disappearing is likely due to...
Okay, it's not!
I don't have it!
Nope, okay.
Turns out...
Okay, but it doesn't!
go into the settings and turn off controller i think it
falls under that's how most games have my controller's not
even plugged in what do they mean okay guys i'm gonna plug
in i'm gonna borderless windows you're so fucking right guys
okay maybe borderless window will work all right borderless
uh windowed mode okay we're gonna do window mode this is it
this has to be it all right we're not watching agility and
again all right where's my crap
all right give me a sec i don't understand we're like the
DLC where did it go I bought the game of the year edition
Todd you already got my money you literally got so much of
my money Todd why are you doing why are you doing this to me
Guys, I unplugged it.
I swear to God.
I unplugged it.
All right, let's see.
All right, now I plugged it back in.
Maybe if I just had my controller on, it will be fine.
I already have my controller on.
Okay.
All right, let's watch this again.
Tied, please.
Okay.
of my money dokey why are you doing that i don't understand
todd where did it go
i hit every key possible
oh my god darn you todd okay i i know how to do this guys
okay we're just gonna We're just gonna go to our folders,
apparently.
Let me figure...
Alright, what was it?
I need to go to the fucking...
I need to go edit a folder again, guys.
Oh my god.
Can I edit the...
Okay, wait.
Is this gonna be, like, Fallout 76?
I'm having the same issue.
Stuff on...
Maybe it will work.
Okay.
Alright, turns out it was my USB...
What the fuck?
Does anyone have...
I found...
Disconnect your mouse.
Press Shift plus tab.
Reconnect your mouse What okay, I got disconnect my mouse
Shift tab reconnect your mouse Todd Please Hey, this is the
authentic the face text like everything works, but my
cursor's not showing up like what?
Why is my cursor not showing up?
tied
okay um try my game would by work worked for me i think
start going exit what is this what press e okay it's not e
guys run this game as app there's no way there's no fucking
way running a game on admin is the all right browse local
files i swear to all right all right we're running it as
admin will it show up will it register that i have a that i
have a mouse cursor will it press a on your usb okay i
plugged in my controller and it didn't work the game was
rigged from the start it was no come on come on
Todd Todd Alright controller settings Steam input Alright
okay Okay your controller No I don't want to fucking Okay
I'm gonna plug in my controller Alright here we go This is
like Tech support with the dry rooms Just like the good old
days Alright here we go Plugged in my controller Alright All
right.
Okay.
All right.
Now we have that we're on controller.
Is that it?
Oh my god.
Okay.
We got our controls display.
Okay, guys.
We gotta figure a way to make it so that we're not on
controller.
I refuse to play this game on controller.
All right.
Okay, how do I...
Controller.
Off.
Wait, okay, does that mean it worked?
Where's my mouse?
Okay, now, does my mouse show up?
Oh, it doesn't look like my cursor shows up.
Guys, maybe it's just the main menu thing.
Guys.
Todd can't be wrong.
I'm trying to plug back in my controller.
I can't fucking fit in the USB slot.
Everything's going wrong.
Oh my god.
Why can't that?
Why doesn't it fit in the hole?
Oh, that's what you want to hear.
Oh no.
Now I have nothing.
Okay.
Guys.
Okay, guys, this is starting to be a little bit of a mess,
guys.
I understand that now I can't even, apparently now I can't
even turn it back on.
Guys, I fucked up.
Why did I turn off the controller?
I fucked up.
I can't even use the controller anymore.
Oh, my God.
I fucked up.
I won't even let me use the controller because I turned it
off Oh no Guys Guys I realized I made a mistake when I
turned off controller It's oh I'm actually broken Wait maybe
it didn't register Maybe it just didn't register guys
Maybe he didn't Don't wait This is all Todd's plan Todd
knows what he's doing I believe Oh I knew it I knew I could
believe in Todd Oh shit Okay no I don't want Wait there's
mods Oh my god Wait Do I have to buy these mods?
Oh Can I install this?
Download Oh everyone's best friends?
Wait Wait Does this mean I can have dog meat?
And, okay, let's have dog meat and stuff.
Oh, this is, oh my God, does this work?
Todd, don't, no, don't buy, don't pay for those mods.
But that's what Todd wants, though.
Todd wants me to pay for mods.
I can possibly listen, but this is amazing content.
Thank you, Super Chat, Mr. Broken Fond.
Thank you, thank you.
God!
Look, if Todd wants me to pay for mods, maybe he's right,
you know?
Maybe he's right.
Oh, these are free?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I would pay Todd, just letting you know, if you monetize
your mods, I would definitely pay for them.
Me and all the Todd believers would 100% pay for it.
Anyway, I can't believe I have to play this on...
I can't believe I have to play this on controller.
Start a new game.
Yes.
Don't give it to all two of you.
Todd, do it.
It'll be so funny.
Okay.
Maybe...
Guys, maybe like my mouse cursor will show up.
Guys.
Just as he...
Just as attended.
Entirely trust.
TV.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If he can get away with Starfield, he can get away with paid
much.
War.
Never changes.
He said the thing.
In the year 1945.
My great-great-grandfather.
in the army, wondered when he'd get to go home to his wife
and the son he'd never seen.
He got his wish when the US ended World War II by dropping
atomic bombs on Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
The world awaited Armageddon.
Instead, something more miraculous happened we began to use
atomic energy not as a weapon but as a nearly limitless
source of power oh my god we did it luxuries once thought
the realm of science fiction surely no one would use it for
bad fusion powered cars portable computers and then the
world and then we discovered world peace right right 21st
century What the fuck give this kid a knife?
Years of consumption led to shortages of every major
resource.
Subtitles, look, I forgot to turn subtitles on because I was
going through a lot.
It's understandable.
It went through like the five stages of grief just then.
In 30 minutes.
for my wife I have a wife wait who's the who's the narrator
is this the lone wanderer the sole survivor the vault
dweller who the fuck is narrating this it's that war war
never changes wow war never changes it's me the chosen one
who is it who is it
oh that's me i'm never gonna have my cursor never changes oh
it was me you think absolutely now get ready and stop
hogging the mirror is default guys supposed to be like todd
oh my gosh okay let me see if i can okay guys unfortunately
um unfortunately i'm gonna have to use this for use the
controller for now all right who do i want to look like oh
my god that light looks like god what's his name that guy
from oh general hucks from from star wars do i want me
ginger again no i want to be a guy because like the girl's a
lawyer and like i don't know i don't think i can i don't
think a lawyer can survive we slept sorry what am i what am
i gonna do like fucking argue myself to safety like be it be
it ginger again all right guys should we be ginger again
you're right maybe i'll serve maybe i can survive my turn
big guy wait actually i don't want him to look i don't want
my husband to look like that like wait let me change him let
me default todd i'll make him i'll make him default todd
real quick where's default todd there it is all right and
then um i'm just saying lawyers are not making in the
wasteland she's like a lawyer apparently all right we're
gonna make her ginger we're gonna go like the fallout 76 way
gingers will survive we're gonna make sure the gingers don't
die out uh let's see how how do i do this okay we oh My eyes
are up here.
Wait, I should...
Were you looking at dragoons?
My eyes are up here.
Okay, let's see.
And then...
Let's...
There we go.
All right, let me make sure that...
All right, let's see.
Let me cook!
Okay, sultry...
okay is there no long hair agent x no what are these names
fairy tales femme fatale does this look like a femme fatale
look i need them to look at my eyes they're the gateway to
my soul can't have them looking anywhere else if i so i can
tell that they're looking at the right areas where's like
natural beauty public defender where's long hair i guess
like in the wasteland you don't want long hair because it's
a to clean um oh i look crazy with that uh i don't know all
right i'll go with i guess elegant blonde brunette purple
let's see maybe i should look crazy So no one will get close
to me
Don't know like oh no we can't get close to her even though
I'm like a lawyer It's all about it's all about like faking
it till you make it, you know So like I should like look
fucked up so that you won't get close to me rough night Oh
shit.
This was literally called crazy warning.
All right uh i guess the pigtails yeah you hairstyle yeah
we'll go with that okay and then color color deep red ginger
oh wait is that okay all right guys i'm beautiful guys i'm
like i'm i'm i'm gingers are dying out because like because
it's a recessive gene so i'm gonna help save the gingers uh
let's see i think that's good and then what else can i i'm
gonna help save i'm gonna save the population we're gonna
repopulate wait i said that wrong wait wait a minute
all right let's see damage what what's the damage oh no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
i can't more freckles no actually i think i'm okay with that
all right let's see uh body all right Like I said in 76, we
gotta be...
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait.
Guys, as I said in 76, guys, it's all about...
Look, the more arm muscle you have, the more attractive you
are in the waistline, chat.
it's all about that muscle they'll hire me because they'll
be like oh shit we need that muscle ginger diamond thank you
super chat thank you we're dying up yes you guys I told you
in the 76 stream I told you um the because like having
having like red hair is like a recessive trait and
apparently there's been like apparently like it's starting
to like be phased out the longer the more years have passed
it's starting to be phased out more and more and more so so
there's like eventually there's gonna be no more gingers
which is so fucked up to think about it's actually it's
because it's like having red hair is a mutation same with
blue eyes uh having blue eyes is a genetic mutation along
with red hair and they're both like considered recessive
genes so like if like obviously if like somebody with like
different colored eyes or colored hair was, you know, got,
like if their wife, husband had like a different color eyes
or hair that's not red hair or red hair or like blue eyes
usually the kids will not have those traits.
So that's why like that's why like gingers are slowly being
phased out because it's a recessive gene.
She called me a mutant
Because to keep the bloodline going for gingers You have to
like You have to like marry another ginger Or like have kids
with another ginger To guarantee red hair But like obviously
like If you do that too long Then we have an issue of
inbreeding So we don't want that We don't want Wait, okay,
wait.
The husband needs...
I just realized.
The husband.
The husband needs to...
Uh...
They're not dying at recesses.
You don't stop existing until there's...
Well, they're like slowly getting phased out.
And so, they're rare and rare.
It's true.
They're rare and rare.
Okay, wait, sound guy.
Uh...
All right.
Sorry, I need to...
Okay.
So we know why he died.
I may be a lawyer, but it doesn't stop me from getting these
games.
There we go.
They're endangered.
Yes, they're like an endangered species.
Okay.
all right there we go i'm i'm i'm ready this is me this is
us
okay with the sound guy wanting me to change all right
settings audio okay sound guy what did you want again i was
too busy customizing my character uh let's see down a little
bit also this I heard that the radio actually gets you
demonetized so it doesn't matter even if I got like strike
by profanity or whatever so like I won't be getting I feel
like I won't be getting ad revenue at all so I definitely
won't be getting any ad revenue guys from this stream so
we're gonna be in it for that uh all right overall up okay
i'll boost up the overall all right i hope this works all
right uh guys should i should i okay no i'm gonna get to a
save state okay i'm gonna save quick save all right guys
should we play around and see see if i can get my cursor
show up this time all right let's try guys i think I think
we can do this.
Okay, I turned the controller off.
Where's my mouse?
Controller off.
Alright, back on.
I see.
Controller off.
Alright, it's back on.
Okay, let's get the subtitles on.
Might as well.
Dialogue, general subtitles.
HUD, Pit Boy, uh actor fade uh all right Todd why oh wow
okay we fucking did it oh my god I told you Todd is always
right Todd never doubt Todd again Chad I fucking knew giving
him more money was the I knew giving him 40 fucking dollars
was the right thing to do like of course he needs more money
guys he needs he has a family to support oh and george thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you and money love
these background music all right just worked doubters you're
all fucking doubters encounter led survival ads okay what is
like hard uh legend you know what i think we can survive
hard okay we're not doing very hard but we'll do hard all
right i think it'll be fine it just works nate hey hun hey
hun just getting ready all right how's the volume now oh hey
it's my robot codsworth whoa
don't spill that my lap
oh thanks codsworth thank you
100% daily value of sugar All right, let's see
Hey, honey That was Halloween Well, there's my newspaper
Wait, we have two newspapers More of the same Oh, sounds
like someone made a sticky I should attend to young shore
Oh, yeah, my kids shot I'm glad we got i wonder how much he
cost wait what the fuck is this fridge oh my god it has a
window so we can see inside that's so smart nuka cola nuka
cola ice cold saddle up salisbury steak that's so smart but
where do i get the ice at the bottom as someone that always
forgets what's in my fridge that is so fucking smart oh my
god okay you know i said like i'm I know the intro by heart,
but I literally forgot what's like in like the setting of
everything because my dad just skips through so fast through
he just speed runs to like to to like getting into the vault
that forgot what everything the setting the immersion was
like all right it's that salesman again oh it's like like
the vault thing he's selling the vault to me Is that my
door?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, that's the back door.
Sorry, the door should have been yellow.
Hello.
Wait, do I need to interact with my son?
Give me a sec.
Where's my son?
Hello, son.
Hello, oh my god, you're so ugly.
You're clearly not ginger.
Where are my freckles?
I told you!
They're phasing out!
My son's not ginger!
How dare you?
he okay there you go hello go on nice to find you ma'am you
can't begin to know how happy i am to finally speak with you
i've been trying for days it's a matter of utmost urgency i
assure you urgency why what's so important oh he had a
nuclear bomb joki joki never changes gone to heck in a
handbasket if you'll excuse my language the big kaboom is
it's inevitable i'm afraid and coming sooner than you may
think if you catch my meaning but how would you know huh so
i won't take up much of your time yeah you're you're
encroaching on my gym time precious commodity i'm here today
to tell you that because of your family service to our
country you have been pre-selected for entrance into the
local vault vault one i've been pre-selected wait what
enough space i don't need if you can fit us all right god i
look good of course why don't you have to pay for it minus
your robot naturally in fact you're already cleared for
entrance it's just a matter of verifying some information i
thought you had to pay hold-ups in the unforeseen event of
total atomic annihilation won't take but a moment wait tell
me more tell me more it's like a pyramid scheme and i'm all
for it pyramid schemes are not a scam because you don't
because if you get to the top
it's not a scam you just don't make it you just don't know
how to work how it works
all I'm saying is that if you're at the middle tier of a
pyramid scheme or like the higher the tier you are in the
pyramid scheme the more money you make so it's not my so
it's your fault if you don't make any okay all right sorry
it's not a scamming at the top That's the spirit.
That's Lucy.
Okay.
Alright.
Strength.
Okay.
We're going to have it on strength and then which one is the
Doki Smash?
Okay.
Um, the strongest lawyer there is.
Don't use my brains as a lawyer.
They're just fully intimidated at that point.
Okay, um, what else is good?
All right, now that I have 12 more points, what else should
I put?
Charisma?
All right, no one's...
Which one's gun?
Guys, guys, which one is gun, by the way?
Um...
Oh yeah, I should put like five in endurance.
Uh, basically G-Haw.
Guys, I need to know which one's gun.
Is it actually agility?
Agility is for pistol.
Okay, there we go.
All right.
I think it's perfect.
I honestly I think agility and perception.
All right.
There you go.
I think we're fine.
I think this is perfect, guys.
look all we need is strength and gun we don't need anything
else worst lawyer ever guys do you not see me guys if i
could i put everything on strength if i could strength
episodes were me like look do you not see my guns i met my
fucking two guns right I did not mean the other gun.
Doki smash.
Thank you for the search chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Real female Doki.
There we go.
Wait, actually I needed like real female Doki.
Let's throw it back to 76.
Alright, accept.
Why can't I accept it?
Huh?
Oh.
There we go.
All right.
I'm real.
Very real.
All right.
That's wonderful.
That's everything.
Just gonna walk this over to the vault.
Congratulations on being prepared for the future.
Thanks again.
We did it, honey!
Peace of mind.
We're in the vault!
For you and Sean, no price is too high.
Good answer.
I have my moments.
All right, here you go.
Cosworth, can you say my name?
Don't worry, Cogsworth.
Mama's here.
Hey, Cosworth.
A little motherly love to quiet the nerves.
Don't worry.
Mama's here to love my child.
Hello, Sean.
My boy isn't giving me any trouble, is he?
Hey, I fixed that mobile on his crib the other day.
Why don't you give it a spin?
Oh yeah, I'll spin it.
Yay!
You see that?
Those are rockets.
And you'll never go to space because you're not smart
enough.
Sean isn't gonna make it.
After breakfast, I was thinking we could head to the park
for a bit.
Weather should hold up.
And do what?
What?
And do what exactly?
The fucking hell our neck.
What?
Press E to shine.
What is it, Cogsworth?
Where's the bomb?
Mushroom.
What?
What did he say?
We do have...
We do have coming in.
That's, um, confirmed reports.
I repeat confirmed reports of nuclear- Let's just sit here
and not do anything.
Can we die in the beginning?
My god.
Oh no, it's happening.
Please stand by.
Who opened the door?
Keep going!
What the fuck?
Open the door!
There's ghosts here too?
Alright.
I wonder if I can actually Todd from the fate of Todd
himself.
He opened the door.
Who cares?
Just leave!
It's life!
Oh my god, you're gonna wait for me?
What a sweet husband!
Don't worry, I in the program i literally just volunteered
i'm going in you guys wait he's the vault tech rep where was
okay okay i'm reporting this wait he doesn't get in that's
so he literally like try to like try to scam you to appear
in this game but it's not a scam guys adult female okay as
me thank you Good luck, sir.
And God help us all.
Oh, my God, look, there's the power army.
Wait, why is your voice so high?
It should be, like, super low because you're in the power
army.
What's going to happen to all those people outside the gate?
We're doing everything we can.
Now, keep moving.
Giant Fox, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Zoom, nuclear launch detected.
Excuse me.
Go, go, go.
Can I tank this?
Can I technically not die?
When will the nuclear bomb drop?
It'll be fun.
Oh, that's just the show.
I thought it was like a thing.
I'm waiting.
When was it going to show up?
These guys are like, please, please, Doki.
Please, open.
Let us in.
Wait, can I...
Wait, I should quick save.
I should.
I mean What's the worst that's gonna happen I die?
Look at me I'm pretty sure I'll just be a fucking Strong
good Man there's no bomb What if it was just a false alarm
You guys don't know that Guys I bet you it's just a False
alarm I literally have 10 durability Like 10 on strength And
what if I become She-Hulk?
I already got, like, the first half of it done.
I just need a radiation part.
Wait, can you actually explore the town?
Oh, my God.
What if I just explore the town?
I've never actually explored the town before.
I feel like it let me because it's scripted.
Why don't they let us in?
10 strength versus now I'd win I mean I feel like I feel
like because it's scripted you're actually allowed to like
guys you weren't allowed to explore the town let's go in
He's fine.
We're gonna be okay.
We'll be okay.
Yeah, guys.
What happened?
Whoa!
Oh my god.
There it is.
Don't worry.
We'll slowly go down.
Yay!
I mean, they have power armor.
They'll be fine.
How was I supposed to know?
I thought it was just a government hoax.
It was a fear tactic.
We did it.
We made it.
I can't believe I didn't turn into the I can't believe I
didn't turn into she Hulk are you alright you're alright
hubby oh yeah bro maybe I should hold the child I feel like
your arms gonna break any moment my spaghetti ass husband no
no we don't don't get caught up thinking about that you're
safe now yeah we're everyone just head up these stairs and
through the door there hey up the stairs all right let's go
yeah that's me real female i thought he was calling my name
but i was like oh my god he said my name but he was just
saying female
You'll need your suits before we take a look.
Hey.
Thanks.
Thank you.
What now?
Oh my god, you made a suit in my size?
It's so difficult finding a shirt that doesn't rip because
of these guns.
Oh, you're going to love it here.
This is one of our most advanced facilities.
Not that the others aren't great, mind you.
It's gone.
Our home.
Everything we had.
Yeah, but it's...
It's better down here.
We get free food and entertainment.
You'll never have to work again.
Oh, we'll be going over all that in orientation.
Just a few medical items we have to get through first.
Welcome to the gun show.
Oh, this is...
Where's my new home?
I hope you'll see this.
Oh my god, we're gonna get Disneyed.
Excuse me.
Just step in here and put your vault suit on.
Alright.
In front of everybody?
I mean, I'm not shy or anything.
I'm very confident about my body.
I worked hard for it.
The pod will decontaminate and depressurize you before we
head deeper in the wall.
Thank you for a whole new life.
Did I change?
Do I keep her in front of Swalton?
Thank you for the super chat, Tom.
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
I look down instead of at my husband and child.
Don't worry.
Don't unfreeze me like don't unfreeze Disney.
Hello?
Oh, my gosh.
I'm looking up again.
That my husband?
Oh my god, we're going to be let go early.
Is it time to repopulate the world?
Are we going to the surface?
Give him the child!
His fucking arms are sticks!
How can you not pull off the child?
Oh, he's dead.
John I'm the backup Look, I'm all I'm saying If my husband
Invest in 10 points in strength That wouldn't have happened
That's all I'm saying He invested in the wrong thing If he
was a fucking lawyer He could have survived.
I'm only a plan B.
I can't believe it.
I worked so hard on these guns.
Oh.
He could have taken...
Exactly.
He could have taken the bullet.
Because I might...
Hello?
How do I release it?
Wait, how are you dead?
The rest are dead as well?
Wait, how are all the...
rest of you dead wait there's nobody in this one wait
there's only two four six eight pods how did you guys die
open i can't do manual release the freezer broke but how did
i live through the freezer
Oh, they like the life support failed, but I lived That's
why you should have invested in 10 in strength, guys They
didn't I lived because of that
They didn't, you're right They didn't invest in 10 strength
Typica Let's transfer Oh Wait, did I not wear my suit yet?
I've worn my suit.
I didn't realize What is my outfit?
How do I look at my inventory?
How do I look at my inventory, guys?
Ugh.
What's the inventory tab?
All I can do is quick save.
So fucking we.
Is it tab?
It's not tab.
I can't open my inventory.
Oh, I can't yet.
Am I actually wearing it?
Oh, I am wearing it.
I am wearing it They just all watched me Oh Oh there's a rat
roach They all just watched me Uh Change in front of them
Security terminal Welcome to Robo Robco industry Uh Well
1-1-1 is designed to test the long-term effects of Suspended
animation on unaware human subjects That's me!
I'm unaware!
Security staff are responsible for maintaining installation
integrity and monitoring science staff activity under those
circumstances are staff allowed to deviate from assigned
duties in subordination or interference with vault
operations are capital offenses security staff are
authorized to use lethal force all right what about the
security logs what's the least the latest one okay last
entry no all clear from Valtek is coming.
We need to leave.
We're all but out of food.
Almost murdered Stanley for dropping a damn saltcracker on
the floor.
A handful of us confronted the overseer about opening up the
vault.
I never knew a man that small could shout that loud.
Now he's locked himself in this office along with the rest
of the side staff.
We're supposed to hand over any food, weapons, and medicines
we have by tonight, or there's going to be consequences.
I've talked to everyone.
It's time.
One way or another, we're getting of this vault oh okay so
everybody just left what date is it today okay so everybody
left at like 78 they ran out of supplies in 78 that's crazy
i thought like all clear and evacuation okay what is this
well tech is classified short-term non-oh it's a short-term
yeah i was gonna see Oh, it's been 200 years.
Okay.
An absence of an all-clear message from Vault-Tec.
The overseer may like to evacuate staff after a mandatory
shelter.
They left.
Yeah, they left after only two years.
There's only supplies for two years.
How do I open my husband's thing?
I'm gonna rob him.
Where is it?
Is there no instructions to open it?
yeah it only like survived for two years that's crazy wait
the control panels next to his pod guys i need to go back
wait what's this i'm gonna sit down i need to rest my legs i
worked only on my arms i didn't realize i could open his pod
as well because i couldn't open my own i can open All right,
time to rob my husband.
Look, it's technically mine.
See, because I couldn't open these, so I assumed I couldn't
open his.
All right, what do you have?
Oh, I got the wedding ring.
Nice, I can sell it for money.
Thank you.
Thank you, dead husband.
Nice.
Now I can have extra income in the wastelands.
It's technically mine.
We shared bank accounts.
all right easy money oh shit it's time it's time this is
what I've been training for get over here oh
dokey smash
there's no pigs in them yeah yeah that's un-inheriting.
This is exactly why I put 10 in straight.
Doki smash.
Where's more?
I'm ready.
I'm gonna try and take as many stuff I can.
I can carry a lot, too, because I have, like, I maxed out.
Overseer Memo.
Remember, use of the recreation terminal is a privilege.
If work performances decline, this privilege may be revoked.
Enjoy responsibly.
Oh, play
Oh, I get to play a game?
What the fuck is...
Oh, is this like donkey?
Oh, oh, wait, I just realized who the enemy is.
Oh, no.
Because I gotta save.
I gotta save my woman.
I got...
Wee.
Yeah.
we we i did it yeah okay let's leave this is top 10 what is
this all right oh i know i just didn't think i'd get there
that fast oh wait i can drink beer is there any negative
guys is there any negative effects to drinking alcohol?
No, right?
I keep accidentally sitting down.
I'm so tired.
Okay, I can take... I can keep the game?
How?
How do I take it?
Okay.
Oops, sorry.
Uh...
Play tape.
Oh, eject it.
Okay.
How do I...
No, I can't.
It won't let me eject it.
It doesn't let me.
it says uh i tried it says oh there it is oh there you go i
did it i had to like leave all right nice is there anything
in the fridge i guess not
any rad roaches any rad roaches around no does no one have
any items for me to steal i can't believe it all right time
to beat up some more rad roaches hello Brad Roaches?
Ah!
There you go.
Oh, shit!
Ow, that hurts!
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Sorry, I forgot.
Electricity hurts.
Doki smash!
There you go.
Nice.
Oh, do you have stuff?
Press the block.
Oh, I need a block.
Okay, I'm gonna block the electricity.
Okay.
Still can't eat yet.
It's this way.
Does that mean there's stuff here?
Press hold lower alt to power attack.
Oh, okay.
Power attack is left alt.
That's such a terrible button for power attack.
I'm going to change that, actually.
Alright.
Quick save.
I need to, like, know what quick save is, too.
Alright.
Mouse one.
Left alt.
I'm going to put that as mouse four.
I don't have a pit boy in.
That's why.
Do I not have a pit boy?
Okay.
Sneak.
Quick save.
I'm going to make it.
This button is reserved.
What is it reserved for?
I don't have it reserved for anything.
Oh.
Okay.
You know what?
I'm going to put quick save as this.
Wait.
What?
Okay.
I'm going to put that back in left.
Oh.
And then I'm gonna put that here.
Wait, what's...
Wait, I can't do it.
It won't let me.
No!
It won't let me!
Okay.
I'm just gonna put it here then.
I'm just not...
I'm just gonna do it the other way.
Smash!
Oh, no.
A little bit of radiation doesn't hurt.
It's fine.
It's like...
It's like eating a banana.
I'm a little hydrated.
Stay hydrated, everybody.
Alright, I'm okay.
Gun!
This is it.
Alright, let's see.
Vault, overseer instructions.
Overseer's log.
Mutiny.
I want to know about the mutiny.
A faction led by the security personnel have turned on me.
Demanding they be allowed to leave the vault.
Idiots!
I will not open the door to be eradicated to death.
out there i'm consolidating the remaining supplies putting
the staff on lockdown we're going to have to start
practicing who deserves what little food we have left i've
been too damn generous with the rations if people don't like
it well that's fewer mouths to feed just let them out
they're gonna die off they're gonna die anyway so let them
oh i guess they don't want to open the bug door because then
like everybody else is gonna get radiation they're fucking
sitting in the crowd a little bit you might as well wait i
want to hear about the systems malfunctioning strange issue
today with pod c3 subject appear to be having heart
palpitations nothing life threatening but unusual realize
almost too late that the pod was malfunctioning the
cryogenic array almost started thawing her out we're not
sure but i suspect the hiccup involved tech's remote
override systems may have sent an iran signal but to keep an
eye out i only hope their systems the staff okay let's see
open evacuation tunnel all right open it open open what
about this okay what's oh that's the one we read earlier
yeah all right yay we opened it gun more gun how do we
unlock this I want it now okay wait what the fuck how did i
wait i can change my pov how did i change my po guys how do
oh it's middle mouse button should i play as like should i
play third person or what first person guys i need lockpick
okay which is better third person or uh first person i can
get it with dog meat oh nice Okay, that's good.
I almost forgot the stims.
Ah, and can be favored for quick use.
I have no idea if I want to play third or first person.
Do we want to look at her more?
Alright, let's see.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Wait, what does it look like?
Okay, maybe it's easier to aim in third person.
lie it was like it definitely okay maybe i was wrong
maybe i was wrong okay but i gotta take this meat though i
hear more
okay q for okay i mean i don't need to reload q for vats It
hasn't taught me that yet.
How many doors is there to sneak?
You do increased damage.
Left control.
Avoid bright light.
There.
I don't really...
It's one guy.
Before melee attacks while wielding, can press mouse 4.
Oh!
Oh, shit!
Boom!
There you go.
Ow.
Uh...
All right.
Oh, pit boy.
Finally, I can access my inventory.
He's dead.
Let's loot him.
I wanted to force anyway.
Miracle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can finally access my inventory.
All right.
Nice.
Got my pit boy.
That's me.
All right.
Let's see.
I'm level one.
Oh, look at me.
That's me.
Okay, I got security, baton, apparel.
Now I'm not marrying anymore.
Wait, what do I look like without...
I'm very confident about my body.
Okay.
Is there, like, perk chart?
Inspect.
How many radiation is there?
It should be fine, right?
Eleven?
That should be fine.
That's like eating a banana.
Okay.
Okay, plus 11.
That might not be like eating a banana.
That might not...
Guys, I have a feeling it might not be like eating a banana.
Okay.
Guys, it's just a little.
It's just a little.
Ooh, look at these fucking arms, bro.
Oh my god, look at my abs.
Wait, where's my abs?
Wait.
Oh, I need to press the button.
I gotta sing in like cryogenic pause like fucked up my abs
okay guys I just need to be a little bit more dehydrated
chat I don't know you guys know this but the but how abs are
like how to get like really pronounced abs you gotta be like
super dehydrated apparently real female
all in the arms why am I because I am very confident about
my body I worked So, I was at gym, bro.
I worked so hard for these guys.
Look at me.
I worked so hard for it.
I might as well show off my assets.
Yeah, you need to be, like, dehydrated and a little...
It's, like, a little bit starved.
Wait, I can, like, fall from here?
Yay!
The outside world!
Let me me out let me out
this is better than stellar blade do you want to change
anything no I'm fucking perfect all right thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you are you interested in any
robot companions
being welcome to the tomato farm welcome welcome I'm perfect
optimal build right there peak performance exactly oh shit
you're right maybe i should put my clothes back on i forgot
about the radiation guys i would love to like show off show
off the goods but like i just remembered about radiation
design exactly oh look see the birds are okay oh nice
there's supplies here there's supplies outside you're
supposed to put that inside eventually the last known
location of the caravan okay i don't know which perspective
i want to play okay we gotta take all these junk here but is
this like oh it's to open the vault from down Hello.
Nice.
Alright.
Find and kill Pyro.
Start Pyro Maniac.
There's so many quests.
A typewriter.
What am I gonna do with a typewriter?
Oh yeah.
I bought the DLC.
I told you guys.
I gave Todd all my money.
Of course.
Like Todd intended.
Because I believe in him.
In his dreams.
To type Doki god where were you living in a vault all right
let's let's steal everything oh hey oh that's a broken uh
system please stop sitting on chairs real female dokey i
think that's gonna be my new name real female please from
dokey fps vtuber ttv facebook uh youtube to real female
dokey I think that's gonna be my new name now.
Oh, those were all the people that were, uh...
I like how it taught me how to run now.
Um, that died outside.
I wanted...
Is that person?
No, that's a tree.
That's a fucking tree.
Okay.
Where do we go?
I don't remember.
Oh, wait.
There's a... There's a person here to my left.
I assume we go this way.
Wait, is this gonna be my future home?
The sanctuary!
gonna be my new home i'm gonna like rebuild this let's find
cogsworth oh my god i can rob people i've never liked my
neighbors anyway that's right i want that lamp all right
give me that fucking pot oh my god bottle caps we're rich
it's in can it's okay my neighbors are dead it's ethical
robbing I'm just being like, you know, the British Museum.
James, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cogsworth!
You're alive!
How did you survive it?
Oh my god, there's another typewriter.
Oh, I can customize my gun.
Uh, short barrel, comfort grip.
Ooh, adhesive.
Improved recoil and hip fire.
You might as well.
I have everything for it.
I should not be upgrading my default gun.
Never...
It's just a scratch.
Alright.
Let's see.
There's people using the radio.
Oh my god.
They know how to use the radio.
That's crazy.
Alright.
Oh my gosh, my neighbors.
Why are my neighbors so poor?
We live in suburbia.
Oh, nice bobby pins.
I found bobby pins, guys.
Nice.
There's no subtitles for radios, unfortunately.
Wait, have I turned off, like, motion blur?
I couldn't tell.
Gameplay, display.
Is there motion blur?
I don't know.
I think there isn't.
It doesn't see.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, is it?
No, that's...
fade.
I couldn't tell if there's motion blur.
Alright, let me like, I'm gonna, like, turn my sense a bit
lower, though.
The sense was way too high for me.
There you go.
Cogsworth!
You're live!
It's...
It's really you!
It's me!
Everything's dead!
We gotta, you know, like, we gotta give it to him straight.
My God.
They did it.
All that fighting.
And for what?
Everything's dead.
Everything's dead?
Ah, yes, the garden.
The posies have been problematic, I admit.
If only sir were here to help, where is he, by the by the
way?
He's fucking dead.
He can't be dead.
Okay, I'm going to be in denial.
He can't be.
Cogsworth, I'm going through the five stages of grief right
now.
We can both be in denial.
Wait, can we actually romance Cogsworth?
I know you can romance people in Fallout.
It's an attraction to calm this dire mood.
It's been ages since we've had a proper family activity.
Checkers or perhaps Shiraz.
Oh, Sean does so love that.
They stole him.
Sean's been kidnapped, Cogsworth.
Sean's been kidnapped.
I'm going to find him.
I'm going to get my baby back.
It's worse than I thought.
You're suffering from hunger-induced paranoia.
What?
From losing my son?
200 years will do that, I'm afraid.
I feel fine.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Just a little bit of radiation.
I sort of like ate a little bit of Radroach meat, but it's
okay.
It's like eating a banana.
He can make me food.
How do you have food?
Wait, you okay?
Why is it yellow?
People would withhold information.
You can attempt to persuade them into sharing boats.
Okay, you okay.
God's worth.
You're acting.
little easy orange medium heart red heart okay look at that
one persuasion one charisma and i'm okay
first way with that one charisma
oh my god he just wants to serve that's all he wants utility
of dusting a collapsed house
trust so true look at you you couldn't even polish yourself
what do you know god's worth i'm the bombs came and all of
you i thought for certain you and your family were a little
radiation super as a tree jay thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you sir was going to present it to you as a
as a surprise well everything happened wait holotape a
holotape yeah what's on it i believe it's a private message
for you my etiquette protocols would not permit me to play
it for myself any standard holotape reading device should be
able to play it back oh like that pit boy on your arm that
should work brilliantly now and i'm feeling sorry for myself
shall we search the neighborhood together sir and young
shorn may turn up yet yeah no no okay yes yeah i need i need
a companion for now i need him to tank damage for me no
don't get near me all right where is the from the map select
map marker with to fast travel to hold to drag to view
anywhere in the map a custom marker.
Where's the holotape?
Where do I look at that?
Radio.
Um.
Is this hi, honey?
Is it this?
Why the fuck did you give me this tape?
I'm already going through trauma, Cogsworth!
Can I rob my own house?
Nice.
Oh my god, please stop sitting on chairs.
I can't I can't believe it.
I'm coming, sweetheart.
Bro, he's fucking dead.
What do you mean?
I can't believe... I can't believe Cogsworth gave me more
trauma.
I was trying to fucking move on.
I don't understand Cogsworth.
Why would you do this to me?
After everything I've been through.
Feels fucking bad, mom.
All right, we gotta...
Oh, there's more?
Did I not loot everything?
Oh, wait, there is!
No, that is just a baby rattle.
That's money!
I can sell Sean's baby rattle.
I'm gonna sell everything that I've owned of Sean so, like,
I can move on.
That's so healthy.
As long as, like, I pretend he never existed.
I'll be okay.
I'll just sell every little reminder I have of him.
The books is on the...
Did I miss the book again?
Did I...
Okay, where the fuck?
one right according your special we're strength I like I
like how it won't let me improve my strength anymore all
right I guess we'll do a little bit of charisma I guess I'll
do a little bit of charisma chat that improved past no more
strength why would it let me improve my strength
Oh, dog bull.
Stop sitting!
I'm sad.
I keep sitting.
I keep fucking sitting.
My legs are tired.
Oh, Nuka Cola.
Nuka Cola.
Bolt fly.
Oh, God.
There's way too much radiation.
I don't remember the concept, but like back then, like,
because you know how like in prehistoric times, the bugs
were like huge, but then i think it's like to deal with like
temperature or something oh how do i do this but like more
years passed by the smaller the insects got uh use a to turn
the screwdriver if you spot the spot is she chosen the lock
will rotate and open if the lock resets release a and
reposition how do i do this
oh oh there you go oh i did it i'm so smart nice oh gosh
there was like oh there was more there's so many items
oxygen oh there isn't enough oxygen now that's great thank
you see deforestation i should say that
finally a good thing thank god all right finish it coward
finish what i don't know what you're talking about got
lighter i got these oh i can turn on the okay i can't turn
on the tv let's see more metal trays oh my god a watch i'm
gonna loot everything There's so much stuff to loot.
This is great.
There's so much ethical robbing I can do.
Alright.
Let's see.
Wait, I could...
Stop sitting on chairs!
Medi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The ones there wasn't really bad after all.
Exactly, Medi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I knew it.
I knew like there was a...
the reason why I like the one slay.
Wait, where's Cogsworth?
Where the fuck did he go?
Did he go here?
Oh, I see him.
He's over there.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, there's a pump.
Oh yeah, because it was Halloween.
Hello?
No, they're alive.
Both my husband and my child are alive.
Sean's out there.
Yeah.
He's out there.
I need to find him.
conquered last i checked they only pummeled me with sticks a
few times before i had to what why did you travel you're
useless you're just he likes it guys don't worry why would
he come back to get pummeled if he doesn't like it i'm sure
you'll find young sean one way or another we're gonna find
sean we did it It's because he likes him, giving him what he
wants, guys.
There must be someone who can help you.
How dare you?
Wait, okay, I need to use the bathroom.
Let me put on the radio for you guys.
It's gonna get demonetized anyway.
Alright.
What's a good radio station?
There you go.
We'll do this.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
I'm back, guys.
You guys like the radio?
Alright, let's see.
Let's loot a little bit.
Guys, we have to, like, we have to find our son, Sean, who's
definitely very much alive.
Alright, let's see.
Where do we go?
Where's my house?
It's like this way.
Okay, we have to go this way.
Ellen, Luca, John, Seth, and Risa, thank you for the super
chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is the water radiated?
Oh, the water's fine.
Guys, it's not fine.
Guys, I've discovered that it was absolutely not fine.
Guys, who would I thought?
Oh, hey, dog meat.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I want to wear his clothes.
Bro, his clothes look so...
His clothes accentuates my body.
all right let's see where is a pair how about the further
you get from the source the harder load be to become okay
let's see postman hat drifter outfit military what's
military fatigue what's that look like oh shit i'm the
postman you're gonna fuck your wife all right i have a
delivery no my pigtails no we shouldn't have a hat all right
here you go and then oh yellow fedora where did i find this.
Alright, no hat.
I need you guys to see my hair.
There you go.
Look, it shows off my build better.
I like that.
Alright, we go this way.
This is where Dogme shows up.
We need him for the gun.
That's the milkman.
Both works, too.
Don't you never heard about the postman, too?
You gotta be careful with the two.
You gotta be careful with the UPS guy.
Dogme!
Hello, Dogme!
Hey, boys.
What are you doing out here all by yourself?
You're okay.
You're a boss.
Where's your owner?
I'm your owner now.
Okay, then.
Let's stick together.
Ah!
Wait, I want to...
Get over here.
I want to pet you.
Wait there.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, I can trade.
Dogme, what do you want?
Dogme, do you want a gun?
Talk to me, take this gun!
Give him toys?
Like, what?
The baby rattle?
I have a baby rattle.
Does he like that?
He's got a gun.
Oh my god, he has a gun!
What is he gonna do with it?
Do I have a toy?
Here, you have a toy car.
Uh, there you go.
Uh...
Let's see it.
Talk.
How you doing, buddy?
How you doing?
You want to play tricks?
You know tricks?
How smart are you?
I do cry.
Oh my god, he's so cute!
Okay, wait, wait, what else?
How you doing?
You want to play fetch?
Think you can find something for me?
Uh, find me container.
Find any goodies, boy.
What's the container?
He's so talented!
Dog meat.
You're so talented.
Why are you barking me like that?
You have a gun.
I gave him a gun and a toy car.
He's fucking strapped.
Oh, there's a workshop here.
Okay, we got...
I don't know which...
I'm going to go with first person.
And then when we're fighting...
What the fuck?
Where did these...
Oh, drop it!
What the fuck happened?
I left for like one.
One second, Dogme!
Holy shit!
I left for one second!
Dogme!
Dogme, shoot him!
Oh!
Shit!
Oh my god!
I left for one second, Dogme.
What the fuck happened?
What happened?
I went to loot!
Dogme, No, you're not getting a stim pack.
You know you can...
I know you can recover your HP.
You can't lie to me.
Stop faking it, dog meat.
See, you're okay.
You don't need a stim pack.
Don't fake it, man.
Dog meat, you get it.
I know he has self-heal.
lie to me heal your he's literally okay what do you mean he
has self-heal i don't wait do i i don't know if i do do i
have self-heal i can't remember dog stop stop stop toky oh
wait no this is we need this okay safe storage wait no i
want to look at the safe storage oh no a dog of a gun
hopefully are not around anyone.
Sharko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dog me is dangerous out there.
Take this out.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Take care of these barrels before you leave tonight.
Inspectors are coming first thing in the morning.
Just hide them with the others.
We'll figure out long-term solutions.
Okay.
What's the last service log?
Replace atomic alternate in a 2073 Coverga.
Oh, hey!
Is that the car?
Okay.
Let's see.
Should we keep the radio on, guys?
Eatronic?
Is there food in here?
No, there's no food in here.
God damn it.
Uh...
Let's grab this.
I still don't know if I want to keep the...
If I want to keep...
If I want to play in first person.
Wait, where's my dog?
Where did my dog go?
Dog me?
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
Command.
Oh, are you scared?
Follow me.
Come on.
Get over here.
Where is the car, though?
Is it this one?
Move here.
Here.
No, stop, stop.
Stop.
Stop moving.
I just want you to follow I'm so sorry I was trying to talk
to you I didn't mean to I did I swear to God I swear to God
I mean oh my god it was an accident it was an accident I
swear I swear to God, it was an accident.
Oh my God.
Where is he?
Follow me.
How do I, like, make him follow me forever?
Do I just take him to the settlement?
I was trying to...
I was just trying to press the button.
I swear.
Hold R.
Why are you whimpering?
I don't know.
why cancel this
no he wants to he wants to follow see come on dog yeah see
tough love it's all about the tough love I swear it was an
accident I was trying why was it why was it on the head
I went for two if I was shot.
When do I name him?
Why is he still called dog?
Okay.
Let's see.
We gotta go this way, I believe.
We'll go this way.
It was an accident, guys.
It's not my fault.
My hands naturally, like, like went to like to his head i
swear oh shit get that shit away from me okay where's the
other bug where does the other one go i'll be okay see this
is exactly why i don't give a stim pack to the dog i like
naturally don't have selfie i have to eat fucking rat roach
meat to stay alive open the door it must be here right no do
not sit on the couch oh hey nuka cola nuka cola nuka cola i
hope you guys are okay that i swap between first and third
person i like to loot in first person but i want to shoot in
third person okay let's see grab all this junk grab psycho
what the fuck is psycho i'm playing on hard Dog meat.
Oh, baseball bat behind the door?
What am I going to do with a baseball bat?
There's no baseball bat, you liar.
What do you mean?
There's no baseball bat.
Sorry, dog meat.
Oh, there it is.
There must be, like, a way to quick shuffle in between,
like, uh, between weapons.
What the fuck?
This is why.
This is exactly why I don't play...
I don't...
play this on i don't shoot in first person there's no
crosshair i'm in concord now let's see how do i what's that
where's the hotkeys to swap like weapons hold f it's not f
oh there is f uh nine okay wait how do i okay i want to swap
my weapons to base spot back
Q.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Okay, and then F.
F9.
There you go.
I beat up some fucking bugs with my bat.
That?
I can play a third person to beat people up.
Hello?
I hear gunshots.
Any enemy?
enemy got to go here oh shit we're gonna help like this
element the was it the minute man or some shit soon I hear
them oh loot but loot though purified water I can sell that
for so much money guys I can't drink yet I can't pick that
no I'm too dumb too dumb sucks I can't be dumb and fucking
jacked.
Is there anything in the Nuka Cola?
Oh, there is.
Is it Preston time?
Hello?
Anyone here?
Oh, shit.
There they are.
Oh, there he was.
Let me loot him.
Oh, my God.
There's a Raider's outfit.
Are you okay, dogmeat?
Did you kill him?
Nice.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to look so pretty.
pretty.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna change my outfit now.
Let's see.
Harness.
Damage resistance.
Oh, wait.
There's, like, stats.
I didn't realize there's stats.
Oh, right leg.
Sack hood with straps.
What the fuck does that look like?
Oh, God.
Okay, no.
We're not covering our head.
We don't need to cover our head.
Bap, bap.
All right, time to loot.
I should save them, but, like, loot is more important.
Anything goes.
Is there fall damage?
Nope.
All right, let me in.
Look.
Oh, there's a Minuteman outfit.
Wait, who?
Oh, there he is.
Hey there.
That's fucking right.
Whoa!
Whoa
Whoops Now like beat his head off Oh, what's the point?
Oh my god, dude I mean, what the fuck?
Stop Guys, it's not what it looks like I swear to God Guys,
it was an accident.
I swear to God it was an accident.
I swear to God, I don't like it happened twice, but I swear
I did not mean to do it I know fool me once shave on you,
but I swear to God
It's not No
I love dogs my best friends and dog guys
Okay Wait, how do I do I it's not reloaded?
Oh, it doesn't have It doesn't have ammo.
There we go I was like, why doesn't it not hitting?
Let's see Got loot while everything is going on There's so
much stuff going on that I can loot Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, I have to reload every...
Oh my god, I do!
I do have to reload every shot.
That fucking sucks.
There's an enemy in front of me.
I didn't see him.
I didn't see him on the map.
There you go.
Easy headshot.
Where's the other guy?
Where is he?
He's, like, in my view, but where?
Can you grab his stuff, though?
Nice.
Yeah, I'm alive.
What are you going to do?
Shoot me?
Can I open this?
God damn it.
I'm too stupid.
Don't you hate it when you're just too stupid?
He does up the clip or so.
Make a compilation.
No, don't make a compilation.
Guys, I swear.
It was an accident.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Select the potential password with mouse one.
If your chosen password is incorrect, that match will be
displayed on screen.
What the fuck am I looking at?
Error?
I can't tell if I...
Oh!
What?
Okay.
Could.
Entry denied.
So not could.
This?
Error?
I'm so confused.
How many words were right?
Did it tell me how many words were right?
Wait, which one did I play?
Okay, I clicked could.
And it says one word.
How about over?
owner.
Zero.
Okay.
So it's not...
Um...
Okay.
So one letter was right and could.
So there's no O's in the word.
So there's no O's.
That's that we know.
That we know there's no O's.
And then there's no... There could be a D.
So it could be sand.
It could be sand.
Or it could be spied.
Because sand...
spied build uh there's no oh okay sand spied build it's the
letter in the same spy it's letter end position oh it's
letter end position oh oh oh okay okay all right so couldn't
be spied because there's no e so it could still be send then
right let's say two four five no because it's like the fifth
so it can't be send two four five it could be spy oh wait no
we just it could be build it could be build for the d
because like could had one likeness and it could be like the
d at the end right like build our third okay we're gonna try
to build likeness okay it's one more so it could be it's
third i it's not guys i'm not locked out guys i'm not smart
enough oh we're set for 10 seconds guys we can wait it out
guys it's okay we can wait it out all right i got this guys
i got this oh it's in new one okay we'll do i got leveled up
for failing i love leveling up for failing lying zero okay
there's no ly ing okay melba spend there's one okay so it's
okay so if there's one likeness there's one likeness so so
it could be like uh it could be d again it can be d again it
could be bonds it's not and that's for sure okay look
there's spend all right so two four it could be the last has
to be a d two okay wait two four five okay it's the fifth is
there any spends it's not there's no more there's no more
okay uh so it's either it's either spe or n oh they're shady
we're shady no that's four because like it's the fifth all
right let's try let's try shady there's two like this okay
it could be s a it it can't be d it could be d though
Wait, can I just lockpick this?
Guys, I'm just going to lockpick this.
Let me be...
No!
It's okay.
My bobby pin is...
No!
There.
Oh, no.
We did!
No.
We did it!
Yay!
Can I still do this?
Okay, let's...
We unlocked it in.
Anyway, okay, anyway, so, all right, so we figure it out.
Okay, there's one likeness.
And,
all right, so there's one likeness.
Okay, now it's just out of pride.
Now it's just, now it's just out of pride now.
All right, range, there's one likeness.
Okay, it could be faces?
There's zero, so it's not A.
We know it's not A because, like, none of this match.
So it's either R, N, G, or E.
So, all right.
There's no other...
There's an R here.
We could try to rely.
Got it.
I did it!
Oh, my God!
We did it!
We unlocked it!
Guys, I fucking knew it, guys.
God, I'm so fucking smart.
There's nothing in...
Oh, there's a power core.
There's a fusion core.
Let's go.
I did it, guys.
I fucking knew I wasn't that stupid.
I knew it.
There's hope for you all.
If I can solve that, you can all solve it.
Where do I go?
There's so many places to go.
Oh, scalpel.
Nice.
Alert Wordle.
I've never played Wordle before.
This is like, this has to be, like, the very first time I've
ever played Wordle.
Chat.
This actually is the very first time.
What's that?
Somebody here.
Oh, shit.
I was like, where's his head?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Give me a second.
I'm reloading.
Guys, it's so nice.
He actually, like...
Guys, it's so good.
He actually, like, fucking waited until I...
He waited until I reload.
Is that great?
People are so, like...
They're so polite.
People are so polite that they waited for me.
He was so polite, exactly.
Anybody here that I can shoot?
I hear people reloading.
But I have no idea where they are.
Alright, let's go up.
It's time to go up.
Dog meat.
Oh, there he is.
Peek me.
Peek me, bitch.
Oh my god.
Oh, shit!
Wait, there's more!
Dog meat, please bite him!
I'm so sorry!
oh i saved him don't say i didn't do nothing i saved him he
was about to get kicked but i stopped him there we go did i
get like double nice there we go oh shit i leveled up how do
i all right nice can i the first thing i do is like can i
can i do more strength
uh punching attacks your quick hands make pocketing easier
toughness uh let's see let ball tech guide you the path you
closest is displayed in vats oh i like that yeah confirm
except i want that what else can i do should i put more in
fortune finder whoa can i i should do more guns i should do
gunslinger Yeah, it's all about the guns Do you have more?
No.
Alright, we got Gunslinger And Useless perk What do you mean
useless?
What do you mean?
Bro, the worst perk?
Which one was the What the best?
Guys, you don't understand.
I'm always lost.
I don't think it's useless I don't think it's useless guys
You just don't understand You don't appreciate the little
things in the world Okay nice We gotta take his clothes It's
the enemy Oh shit sorry
That'd be so unfortunate if i killed a essential mpc
all right let's see
oh hey all right this way uh if you don't use it use it it's
i'm gonna use it all you just just wait and see guys i'm
gonna use it all i'll let you in a little dirty little
secret you can get more stats above 10 if you use the boost
actually just don't get addicted johnny thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you oh wait what talk to me
minute man minute man so now i'm traveling backward in time
protect the people at a minute's notice that was the idea so
i joined up wanted to make a difference and i did but things
fell apart now it looks like i'm the last minute man last
one what happened where what about the people around you
aren't they men and men too yeah who are these people who
are these people just folks looking for a new home a fresh
start I've been with them since Quincy Lexington looked good
for a while but the ghouls drove us out of there the ghouls
a month ago there were 20 of us I mean yeah there were eight
now we're five They just left you, right?
They didn't die, right?
Start meeting dinner.
And this here is Sturgis.
Okay.
It's a cruel...
Sounds rough, buddy.
Sorry.
Sounds really rough.
Thanks.
It's good to meet someone who really cares.
Anyway.
We figured Conquered would be a safe place to settle.
Those raiders proved us wrong.
But...
I do have one idea.
Tell me.
Well, I'm being assertive.
There's a crash vertebrate up on the roof.
Old school.
What?
You might have seen it.
Well, looks like one of its passengers left behind a
seriously sweet goodie.
We're talking about...
I'm lunching pizza.
T-45 power armor.
Military issue.
Oh, power armor.
I like it.
I like it Yeah, I thought you might protection with an added
bonus Get the suit you can rip the minigun right off the
birdie bird Those raiders getting express tickets to hell.
Sturgis tell her are you still telling her?
Minigun like a rifle don't see why not it'll have a manual
trigger just aim it at the back guys knew the old spray and
prey now as for the armor it's out of juice probably has
been for a hundred years it can be powered up again but
we're a bit stuck hmm I'll help you I have a power fusion
core a standardized fusion core your high-grade long-term
nuclear battery used by the military and some companies way
back when we know right where to But we can't get to the
damn thing.
It's down in the basement.
Wait, I got it!
I have it right here.
I tinker.
Bypassing security ain't exactly my forte.
Wait, I'm smarter than Preston!
Guys, I'm smarter than him.
I already have it.
I already grabbed the fusion core.
We're set.
Well, alright.
You guys gotta say I'm not smarter.
I'm smarter than this fucker.
I'll inject the coin to the power armor and grab that
minigun.
they picked the wrong fight good luck i did it guys i did it
you okay what's going on careful are we getting out of here
this is mama murphy little mama murphy oh he did give him
her name look at you dog meat he's a good boy good dog smart
too oh indeed dog meets good of finding folks who need him
And he'll stick by you now.
I saw it.
You saw it?
It's the chem's kid.
They give old mama Murphy.
Oh, she ain't...
She's not been okay for a while.
As long as I can remember.
The sight?
What's the sight?
I can see a bit of what was and what will be.
And even what is...
Where's Sean?
Where's my kid?
I
can see This something coming are they all bulletproof just
just like I need to be sure if I don't want accidentally You
know What oh it can't be me.
I'm perfect.
What is it?
Mama Murphy.
I need more, please What I How did it fail?
Look at me!
Might as well be intimidation.
When I tell you, it ain't a raider.
But I'm tired now.
But even me and my one charisma didn't persuade her.
I don't understand.
Me and my one charisma should have worked.
you all right oh hey there's a pit boy oh your person has
been permanently creased by one yay no risk that's two where
do i go now oh yeah we gotta go up how do i go up let's see
do i still want the radio on or should i turn it off chat oh
yeah it's two now
all right loading radio on all right we'll keep it on it's
not too distracting right it's crazy that you have this
little wrist you you mean putting it all on shake was not
the right idea no way that can't be true but all those gym
bros told me it's in told me it was cool that's how you get
on the ladies My God, the loading time is fucking insane.
Michael, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You should raise your endurance to five, then get Aqua Girl.
Water can't hurt your radiation anymore.
Only we drink it.
You can swim.
Okie dokie.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my God.
What the fuck is this loading time?
What the fuck?
No, it's moving.
See, look.
I told you.
It's moving.
It's nighttime now.
is this cannon or did i just take too long
all right here we go
oh i got the minigun okay we gotta grab the scissors am i
getting shot at it's okay we're fine look at my minigun
though wait where's the power armor show me that fancy gun
up close wait it's over here what am i supposed Wait, give
me a sec.
Dogme, please.
I need to go down.
There's something over here.
Oh, there's...
Guys, I forgot to...
I missed the...
I thought that was a person.
I literally thought...
I literally thought that was a person, so I walked past it.
Don't worry.
I got my power armor now.
Wait, where's Darya?
I got my mini gun.
Doki, smash.
Wait, is that?
Okay, I was going to say it.
I hope I didn't accidentally shoot the wrong person again.
Doki is ready to smash.
Get over here.
Where is he?
I loot you?
Nice.
Wait, what's that sound?
Oh!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, it's okay, it's okay.
I can out shoot it!
I have so much strength!
Oh, I can take this!
Oh!
It's alright.
If I just...
Oh, shit!
Bro!
Whoa!
Whoa, he's fucking beating me up!
Oh, shit!
Don't make me do it!
something oh guys guys i don't feel okay i don't guys i
don't feel okay guys what's my stim pack zero okay
all right so what i learned
is that death clause i forgot how strong death clause are
guys
that was uh it's so that was that was a little bit of a
skill diff there all right it's okay round two round two
rematch time it's okay this is why we have round two but we
got somebody up here we where is he this is just like the
fallout oh wait you're right vats what was vats again what
button activates vats it never taught me
okay what the fuck why is this guy not taking damage that
was a lot of bullets out here.
There we go.
Alright.
It's Q or... Alright, give me a sec.
Just reloading.
There he is.
He's coming over now.
I hear him.
There he is.
Alright, don't worry.
He doesn't see me yet.
He doesn't see me.
Do you think he sees me?
I don't think so.
Darling, no!
Oh my god.
Oh, 69.
69.
Where's the head?
There's a belly?
Oh, don't.
Shoot.
Guys, I should have fucking did 69.
I...
Oh, no!
Not the raider!
Oh!
No, not the suplex!
Oh, my God!
Oh, you can't go in the building.
It's too thick.
That's fucking right.
I know you can't enter the building.
You're way too fucking sick.
That's fucking right I knew it.
What you gonna do?
You're way too wide for this What the fucking glitch did
That's illegal
What He actually forced himself in.
All of these things, Todd.
He had Todd cheese.
Oh my god.
He pulled it off.
He chewed.
He fucking no clip inside the door.
How the fuck did he do that?
Oh my god, that's actually crazy that that happened I did
not I just cast thank you It just works.
It just works.
It just works I didn't think that was possible I didn't
think you could actually no clip inside Oh my gosh, fuck
this I'm just gonna whoop then i'm gonna run then i'm gonna
run i'm gonna run it just works it just works okay
apparently his belly all right guys you think i hit it
oh my god i can't believe he forced himself inside no Where
the fuck is this belly?
Hey, belly.
Phew.
Oh, I'm going to do this again.
It's going to work this time.
There's no way.
There's no way he'll clip in again.
There's no fucking way.
Wait, he's gone.
Wait, did I despawn him?
I did it.
I despawned him.
What?
nice oh my god i did it he just left guys he just fucking
left where the fuck happened he ran off he knew he was so oh
shit he beat oh my god he was bro he fucking left again he's
running it's like it's like fucking i see you it's like
green light it's green light red light bro he's flipped a
car oh my god you just know there's no way you're gonna
phase through that door again there's no fucking way you're
gonna do that to me again he's on predator mode wait where
did he go okay nice he's only i don't even i can't see oh
there's my ammo There's no way I'm going up the stairs.
There's no way.
I'll cheese him
Get fucking cheesed you fucking whore Okay nice There you go
shoot him from here.
I'm not scared of cheesing all right reloading Not even it's
in it for the hunt for you I hate it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where did he go?
He's in predator mode again.
I hate it when he does this.
Just fucking show up and let me shoot you.
Like, where did he go?
He's in predator mode again.
Where did he...
Get up, Dogmeat.
I know you have self here.
I don't like this.
I don't know where he is.
no don't whimper makes me sad when you whimper okay i know
you're just oh no there he is there he is i have too much
junk in my fucking inventory now oh no okay wait i just
gotta eat if i eat it'll be okay all right let's get some oh
hey it gives me like it makes me smarter You know what?
I can eat a little bit of a roll.
Okay, let's see.
0.5, 0.1.
All right, we need to get rid of stuff.
We need to start getting rid of stuff right now.
Okay, let's see it.
The iron.
Oh, that's like plus two.
Okay, we gotta...
How do I throw this away?
Drop.
All right, we're gonna drop this.
And then...
No, we do not put out our pistol.
Wait, where's my minigun?
oh i never dare you don't keep to go to fist fight the death
claw treasure thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you
okay give me a sec guys i need to figure out how to where is
he where where's my minigame oh there it is okay i shot him
where is he god okay we're gonna fist fight him when he's a
little lower okay don't worry bro he tried to fist fight my
dog don't worry guys all right you guys ready i'm ready wait
how do i okay i'm ready this is it i've trained for this
this is it fight me i got you one hp it's time
It's fucking time.
Get over here, Deathclaw.
Bro, he came back.
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Guys, I think I made a mistake.
Guys, I absolutely made a mistake.
But what if I just fight him here?
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
It's okay.
How does he have a longer range than me?
Oh!
Ah!
How does he...
He has a longer range!
It's not fair!
Ah!
Guys, I'm running out of stims.
I'm running out of stims.
Have you seen it?
Have you seen his art?
This is gonna work.
This is for the Akasupa.
Oh my god, this is not okay.
This is not okay.
Okay, don't worry.
I can do this.
Come back.
I got this.
I'm going to use VATs for my fist.
Boom.
Ah!
Did it!
There we go.
We might have used a lot of our stims, guys.
That'd be combo.
We fucking did it.
We lost a lot.
But we did it.
Not even close.
I definitely have, like, zero stims.
It's John Cena!
Alright, it was worth it.
It was fucking worth it, guys.
Yeah, I don't have the sims anymore, guys.
I don't have sims anymore.
Alright, Doki Smash.
I knew investing in strength was the way to go, guys.
I fucking knew it.
Alright, we gotta get rid of stuff.
We actually have too much junk now.
Uh...
But what can we get rid of?
Everything is so important.
Everything's so important, though.
Nice.
I don't know what to get rid of.
Okay, we could get rid of.
Bro, all these guns are so important.
Eat the food.
Okay, wait.
But the food won't help.
Get rid of the power armor.
Do I just take off my armor?
Okay, a pair of...
Where is it?
How do I get out of it?
Do you really need five?
Yes.
Okay, maybe you're right.
Maybe I should...
Okay, I'll get rid of one.
All right, fine.
All right, there you go.
Fine, I'll get rid of it.
All right, nice.
Now I can loot.
Where was I supposed to go?
Did I go back?
Oh, I have to go back.
Okay.
Hello, guys.
back back to the loading screen are you not entertained i
fist fight a monster and i lived andreus they give a five
give the ships they could thank you
i did it guys
oh hey more loot that was a pretty oh yeah you saw me run
away and then came back to beat him up that's me is everyone
okay you guys gonna be okay now yeah for a while anyway we
can at least move someplace listen when we first met you
asked about the minute man one thing you should know about
us we help out our friends so here for everything you've
done thank you oh shit fusion cell and he gave me money it
i'll take what i can get spoken like a true murder well if
you ever feel like fighting for something other than
yourself you should meet up with us in sanctuary pay me i
don't do things for free get things done doing what what
would i need to do yeah you'd need to stay strong like
you've been because there's more to your destiny it is i've
seen it And I know your pain.
Destiny.
What's that bullshit?
What do you mean?
You are a woman out of time.
Out of hope.
But all is not lost.
I can feel...
My son's alive!
What's his name?
He's alive.
Bullshit.
You're trying to play me for a fool.
Yeah.
What's my son's name?
the site's sometimes foggy but it ain't ever a liar your
son's out there and even i don't need the site to tell you
where you sounds like a scam like fortune tellers great
green jewel of the commonwealth diamond city diamond city
that's where the radio's from diamond city what's in diamond
city is sean there look kid i'm tired I'm tired.
Wow.
Gotta give him an addiction.
Gotta be this guy to get you.
Why do they always do this to me?
They give me like a sneak, a tippet.
They hook me in.
He's gonna need it too.
Now let's get going.
She needs to hook up.
All right, folks.
Thanks to our friend here.
It's safe to move out.
We're heading for that place Mama Murphy knows.
about sanctuary that's my house not far she knows about it
you mean she had one of her visions while she was stoned out
of her guard wait that's my house y'all pay rent for that
shit better plan than mama murphy saw it it can hold on hold
on everybody just take it easy we're all in this together
right so marcy you got a better idea of what we should do
next yeah what do we do next
Let's just hope it lives up to its name.
Wait, what I do?
I want to talk.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'll get these people to sanctuary.
We need to keep moving.
What the fuck?
They're heading to my place.
I wanted to pay rent.
We gotta have a rent agreement.
We need to have an agreement.
Look, I am the sole survivor of that neighborhood.
So that makes me queen of the neighborhood.
That's how it works in suburbia.
I am the HOA.
I'm the new HOA.
I am the new landlord now.
If everybody else is dead, that makes me the president of
the HOA.
Because I'm the last one.
I like how, like, the radio is still playing, but this
fucking loading screen is forever.
Like, what?
all right we need to keep moving we need to keep moving
right behind you oh my god i'll wait for you at the
sanctuary i'll let i'll get up all right yes you guys are
gonna be there regardless
oh shit another loading stream whoops you know what i feel
like by the time i get there by walking the loading stream
will be over I feel like.
Not gonna lie.
Is he here?
Wait, he's not here.
Is he actually going to take that long to get here?
Oh my god.
Where is he?
Cogsworth.
Did you see the new people yet?
Welcome back.
Able to find some assistance in Conco.
Uh, new friends.
You could say that?
I made a few new friends.
Can't have enough of those these days.
I realized that I'm No, Mr. Gutsy, but if needed, I'd be
Amadwelf.
Oh.
Is he good?
Your preference?
Would you like to?
No.
Not now.
All right, then.
Is he a good companion?
Kinda?
What does he do?
all right let's sleep we need to find a bed where the fuck
is a bed he can wear a hat oh my okay not gonna lie that's
actually very tempting
yeah all right let's try cogsworth out where is he where the
fuck did he go where Where did he go?
What the fuck?
How could you walk so far?
What's that?
No power?
Oh shit, no power.
Alright, we'll just leave this here.
Alright, Cogsworth.
We're gonna make you come over.
Cogsworth.
I want you to wear a funny hat.
I'd like to trade some items.
Wait, how do I make him wear a hat?
Do I have hat?
Where's hat?
hat hat hat hat hat hat are you gonna wear it
store wait no where's the hat does he wear a hat if I give
him a hat oh give it to him okay uh where's the hat I've
been lied to I can't believe it I was lied to he doesn't
wear a hat he only wears a bowler hat you have preferences
Yes, of course.
Oh,
no!
Your mistress is in good hands.
Oh, my God.
He whimpered.
You just live in sanctuary hills.
I'm sorry, bro.
If I accidentally shoot the robot, no one will complain.
It's for the sake of it.
both of us okay okay let's see we need to find a chair to
sit down or it's taller too all right here you go let's see
we gotta wait oh it's like it is real time okay five hours
all right i waited i just sat on this chair and waited are
you there now you walk over here yet where is he oh he
finally made it fucking finally only shit excuse me hey good
to see you again i was hoping you'd show up i should have
listened to mama murphy all along pretty nice place she's
found for us i think we could settle down here make it a
found for us this is my place wait give me a sec i'm gonna
make sure apparently we have to take back the fusion core
stolen where's the fusion core where the fuck did the fusion
core go i'm gonna steal no i'm carrying too much no i
already used it up cogsworth carry this cogsworth i need you
to carry i need you to carry all my heavy where is it okay
where oh it was used up oh okay where's the like okay wait i
need him to carry all my useless stuff so like i'm i'm
getting way too much stuff right now all right let's see
where's the where did i put the oh my god there's so many
things t45 sort by weight i can sort by weight where oh z
okay sort by tell oh here it is yeah take all of this take
all of that nice okay then is it by weight i can't tell my
inventory weight three oh yep there it is this has to be
that has to be all right we got the minigun out of the way i
don't know if i'm sorting by weight right now things that's
sorted by It doesn't tell me.
It doesn't tell me.
Which one?
Wait, now it's weight?
I can't tell.
Okay, 12.6, 10, 9.
Oh, this is weight.
This is weight.
Okay, Drifter's outfit.
You take this.
And then you take this.
And then, there you go.
That should be nice.
Thank you for carrying my stuff.
He's like my little...
He's like my caddy.
Hello.
Anyway, I am glad you're here.
Wait, did I fuck up the conversation?
But I've got another favor to ask.
I've had word from a settlement asking for help.
What?
Still hoping there are Minuteman out there somewhere.
The only chance to start rebuilding the Minuteman is to show
people that they can count on us when they need us.
Trouble is, I've got my hands full here.
go help out the settlement what have to oh good i was hoping
for a chance to rescue some more helpless villagers it's not
that people are helpless they just need someone to give them
a helping hand sometimes that's what the minute man is
supposed to be i want to be a minute man you guys do it for
free talk to sturgis i'm sure he'd be glad for all the help
he can get
But what if I just want to settle?
Do I have meds for you?
Yes, I was literally born here.
My energy?
What do you mean?
Thought I told you before, kid.
I saw you leave that icebox.
I know your pain.
Which faction's the best?
Which get...
Okay, let me rephrase this.
Which faction gives me the best stuff?
I don't care about more than...
We don't need the good ending.
Wait, here you go.
Here, have some chems.
I already have some.
Make a little kick yourself, huh?
This will do.
Now, let me ride the high to where the site wants to take
me.
How much a companion?
He likes me!
But they're locked tight.
and what they know but people's hearts are chained up with
fear and suspicion but you find it you find that heart
that's gonna lead you to your boy oh it's it's oh no if i'm
if i refuse pressing too much he'll refuse to travel with me
oh no that's what you need to do kid follow my heart i gave
you and he told me to follow my heart.
Phew.
Wow.
That took more out of me than usual.
I'm gonna need to rest now, kid.
What the fuck is that advice?
You want the best stuff?
You need ballistic armor.
Get that from the railroad.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where's Preston?
What kind of advice was that?
could just watch a disney movie for that shit.
Follow my fucking heart and I give you like 100 like 100
bottle casts worth of chems.
What do you need?
What kind of help do you need?
Well, for starters, we could use some real beds.
We've been sleeping on the ground for too long.
Aren't you used to it?
No.
I can't help right now.
Ha!
Let me know if you change your mind.
Okay, I changed my mind.
Yeah, I changed my mind.
Why can't you do it?
I need my help to build beds.
Look, we got a lot on our plate.
And we've been on the run for weeks.
We need food, water, water.
The Institute lets me teleport?
Bro, might as well join the Institute.
Who needs walking?
Yeah, sure.
I'll give you guys bed.
Good deal.
Just make sure we can sleep with a roof over our heads.
Some of these old houses still look solid enough to do the
trick.
There's a workbench over there you can use.
Give me a holler if you need anything.
Medi battle better power armor and liberty prime with the
brotherhood and free helicopter rides yeah but i can
teleport thank you for the super chat medi thank you thank
you more off move options with arrow keys press to find
object you wish to build the belly pierce red try adjusting
your location okay i can build like i can build objects now
all right I can build a chair.
They need a bed, right?
Okay.
Raider, cages, structures, furniture.
Alright, they need a bed.
Alright, here.
Have a fucking bed.
Uh.
Is that enough?
20% happiness?
Why are you sad?
I gave you a fucking bed.
wait i can give him a sleeping bag oh my god you guys should
have told me that earlier what the
why did you tell me that earlier that's so much better okay
wait uh where's the beds okay all right there you go sleep
on you get to sleep oh wait can't put this under There you
go.
One lucky person can sleep under this bed.
All right.
And then in the house.
It'll be fine.
Nature.
Look up in the sky.
You know?
You get to like look up and see the wonderful stars.
The bunk bed.
Exactly.
It's bunk bed time.
Fine.
You sleep here.
Sleep next to the toilet.
All right.
nice uh paintbrush removed let's see um and then i don't
know sleep here wait i can put it here somebody will figure
out how to get in there
and the lucky person gets to sleep on this bed oh this is my
bed right here
one lucky person i.e me gets to sleep on this bed let's go
that's where i'm gonna be sleep and i'm next to the toilet
and the showers yay
that's me my privilege all right well to open the wall in
the build area what oh i can like build stuff here my dad
loved the workshop part of this so i need food water a bed
and shall increase yourself by providing each seller with
all the basics do i have to what if i don't stay sharp don't
let your guard down how do i assign people hey there i knew
service would find something to keep you busy wait i can
assign people stuff how the seller with all the basic
necessities It says unassigned.
What the fuck is he gonna do?
Once the base system can also increase the overall happiness
by raising the settlement's defense rating, this will reduce
the chance that your settlement will be attacked.
My settlement's gonna be attacked?
Wait, cages?
For what?
Arenas?
What the fuck is this?
There's like arenas and areas.
Everything?
Crafting.
Oh my god.
They can make stuff?
Stores?
What the store is going to do for me?
Okay.
Resources.
Water.
Food.
Do I have to give them?
Oh, like I can build this.
No, I don't have concrete.
Oh, never mind.
I can't build this.
Can I build food stuff?
No, I'm broke.
Okay.
Oh, defense.
Power.
Oh, I have power.
How do I?
Power time.
I can build a generator.
I don't know what's gonna do, but I can build it.
Oh, this builds five.
Alright.
I don't know what that does.
But it's there.
Scrap the town.
Okay, I'm gonna scrap my stuff.
How do I scrap?
Uh...
How the fuck do I scrap?
Transfer?
Guys, how do I scrap my stuff?
How do I do that?
I have so much junk.
Like, look at this.
Transfer all junk.
Point out rubble and there's options to scrap.
Oververse, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Plenty of follow-up for what's the over-under.
Allowing yourself to be constantly sidetracked by the
Minimum.
Thank you for that super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, okay.
Transport, store all junk?
That's a lot of junk.
All right, what did I do after that?
Then press T?
I did it.
And then what?
Now scrap it?
Where?
Did I press V?
How do I store?
crap that's it and then you're good do i have everything oh
it does it automatically oh oh okay i should be able to get
resources now right no i'm still i still don't have steel
okay i don't have carrots i can make oh i can make a
scavenging station and a bell what the fuck am i gonna do
with a bell Then look at the item to scrap.
How do I scrap my items?
Raider cages.
Now scrap the town with R.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna do it.
We don't need trees.
Alright, we'll scrap this house.
Let's see.
Concrete!
my god we don't need houses whoa all right um and then i
should be able to build resources now all right power
resources does this require power it produces water okay you
guys gonna have water now congratulations and then they have
water i guess i should give them food resources Can I
produce anything?
No?
Can't build anything.
Does this not require power?
What else requires power?
Power connector, power light, power miscellaneous, local
gates, manufacturing, power, neon.
Oh my god!
But what if I have a neon sign?
D for Doki.
This is mine.
Here you go, I did it.
Does this work?
Is it on?
Wait, why isn't it on?
D for Doki Town.
How do I connect it?
I have a generator right here.
Turn on!
Power!
Power in my fucking town!
I gotta connect the power I have to be an electrician oh my
god bro what how the fuck do I fucking place this okay um
how a conduit what the fuck I don't understand
do i do i just place this is it connected i can't tell okay
here's a conduit okay i got the conduit there we go are you
connected Are you connected now?
Wire them?
How do I put a wire?
Go over to that generator.
Oh my god, I'm doing it.
I'm doing it.
Get in.
okay it's not it's just not connecting why is it not
connecting i need another conduit i need a oh my god okay
conduit what kind of conduit do i need put wire on the d i
could put wire on the d I can get the wire and put it on the
D.
You guys lied to me.
I can't attach it anywhere.
Build something that...
Where can I attach this?
Be careful.
Don't get electrocuted.
What the fuck is this for?
I can't believe it.
I couldn't put the wire on the D.
It's too far.
Do I need another one?
Okay, wait.
Guys, we're slowly learning how to be an electrician.
We're just, it's just very slow.
No, I don't have...
Okay.
We don't have enough copper!
I give up.
This town doesn't...
Fuck this town.
I give up.
This town doesn't need it.
Who fucking cares?
Guys, I fucking, I give up, man.
I fucking give up.
This is too difficult.
You know what?
This is way too difficult to understand.
I'll figure this out at another time.
My brain isn't working today.
Or tomorrow.
Wait, why can't I open my...
Can I open my Pit Boy?
Where's my pit boy?
I have one intelligence, guys.
We all know that.
Why can't I open my pit boy?
Is it because, like, it needs me to finish this tutorial?
I am pressing tab.
It won't let me...
It wouldn't let me open my pit boy anymore.
I'm pressing tab.
Is it because I...
Is it because I refuse?
Oh shit.
No.
That's not the right one.
Oh, there you go.
That's I.
Okay.
I wanted to level up.
Alright guys.
What do I actually get?
Apparently I.
Apparently I chose the wrong perk.
Guys.
So what should I actually do?
Apparently I chose the wrong perk.
So what perk should I really do.
Intelligence?
Check one's under strength.
I don't want to do like iron fists though.
Let's see.
Swing do 40% more damage.
Intelligence for faster XP.
Do I really not smarter the better.
All right, fine.
I'll be, I'll be like, I read a book, so I'm a little bit
smarter now.
I read a book, guys.
Are you happy now?
I did it.
I read a book.
All right.
Idiot Savant.
Wait, idiot Savant?
What's that?
Idiot Savant.
Where is idiot Savant?
where is that life giver awareness luck for more loot oh i
don't have enough luck for idiot savant where is that i have
to scroll down it won't let me scroll down oh oh what
whoa that's a lot of stuff i did not see
I was like, whoa, that's all I have.
That's all I have.
Nara, thank you for the Aka.
Oh, holy shit.
Thank you for the Aka, Aka, Aka, Aka, Aka.
Super.
Thank you.
Money for Doki's electricity fund.
I instinctively try to add seven to that title somehow and
say a lot about my priorities.
I'm not sorry.
Go Doki.
Go.
Santiago.
Thank you for the Aka Super.
Thank you.
looks like my childhood city is so nostalgic thank you the
hacka soup but thank you thank you i can't believe there's
there's so much more oh my god holy it's okay i'm getting
better now all right let's we gotta go this way oh man i ran
out of stamina can't believe i can run out of stamina I
forgot where to go Uh There's so many places Okay let's see
there is I'm here Uh Concord Where's the settlement
technically?
Talk to the settlers I don't care about the settlers Let's
just go a different direction Let's go this way and see if
we can find a quest Why am I tired already Oh no Guys I
should have fucking worked on my legs guys.
Luck is good to have.
Okay, we'll level up luck later.
We'll keep our intelligence too.
Let's go here.
There's houses here.
Oh no, I'm going back to Concord.
Whoops.
I want to go a different direction from Concord.
There has to be a random quest somewhere.
Alright.
How do I not toggle run?
Yeah, but I can only sprint.
Get out of combat mode?
I can get out of combat mode?
How do I get out of combat mode?
Holy shit.
Tago walk off?
Where is that?
Oh, it's caps lock?
Oh!
I didn't realize I had caps lock on.
Oh, there we go.
Hold R.
Oh, I can run faster now!
I'm learning so much, guys.
Okay, we're gonna go past this area.
There has to be, like, a secret quest somewhere.
Not a secret quest, but there has to be something.
What's that?
Why is that red?
Is that...
Oh, that's a car.
Alright.
There has to be somebody here.
No.
We gotta touch the radiated grass.
We gotta go outside and touch some grass, Cogsworth.
You haven't been outside of the home for years now.
Gorski Cabin.
Does someone live here?
Hello?
Knock, knock.
Oh!
Cogsworth!
Help!
Alright, nice.
Be bait!
Good bait!
Oh, shit!
It's okay.
You're a robot.
People won't try to cancel me if I accidentally shoot you.
There you go.
Oh, I had to reload.
Oh my god, he's so strong.
oh my god he's so strong whoa my hero fuck i accidentally
used a step okay sorry that was very feral the fuck
sorry i hate i was very that all right here you go let's
open this door Hello.
Are you dead?
That should work.
You should die, right?
How did I?
What the fuck?
Okay.
I might as well shoot it myself.
I have better aim if I shot my...
If I shot with my own fucking raw aim.
Oh.
Oh shit, let's...
What can I craft?
No, nothing I really want to craft.
How did I miss?
Exactly how?
I should have just shot myself.
Oh, nice.
More junk for me.
More junk for me to scrap and never build on in my
settlement.
Okay.
Got to the cabin.
There's like nothing here.
It just works.
Where are the people?
Give me quests.
So I can get money.
God, look at my fucking broad shoulders.
That's all I want.
There's a basement?
There's people in there?
You thought you could hop from me, you quest?
guys gamers don't look down how the fuck was I supposed to
know that there was a basement all right here we go I'm
coming over coming over oh my god there it is oh no it's a
loading screen my biggest enemy loading screen hello Who's
in here?
There's a weapons?
Let's see.
Can I prove my... No, I can't.
There's nothing I want to prove.
I can rename it.
I'll rename it.
Wait, how do I have rename?
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, wait, that's not it.
Where's my gun?
I accidentally named it T.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Dragoon Buster.
There you go.
Uh, exit.
Yeah.
T.
Alright.
Meme it after you guys.
I don't even know if it's a good gun or not.
Fuck.
Oh, no.
There's nothing in here.
Hello?
Anybody in here?
Do you guys have quests to give me?
Whoa, why is that blue?
Hello?
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
Wayne Gorksky.
Who the fuck are you?
Who the fuck is Wayne Gorksky?
Are you important?
Well, you got fucking bottle caps.
I hope he wasn't important, guys.
guys i hope i didn't kill anybody important he's dead now so
let's see wayne's wasteland survival guide you collect an
issue of the wasteland survival guide diamond city is now
permanently marked on your oh hey i got to go to diamond
city now Oh, there's radiation down here.
That'll be fine.
Password required.
Oh, no.
Uh.
Rest.
Zero.
Rose.
One.
Okay, it's obviously not R.
So it has to be either OS or E.
OS E.
Oh, okay.
How about four?
Oh, it's O.
It's O.
Okay.
it's oh core it has to be core wait no it can't be core it
could be foul or uh it's foul i got locked out it's not foul
guys it's okay it's just plus four guys it's okay i ate like
four bananas guys it's okay that'll be fine it's just four
bananas guys it's just oh now it's five six bananas oh nine
bananas it's okay now there's nine bananas inside me.
Pray.
Okay.
Not gone.
It's G-O-N-E.
Okay.
Maybe more?
Two!
Okay.
It has to be... It has to have M-O or R.
O or R.
O-R.
It has to have M-O or R.
Uh...
O-N-E?
No, it can't be E because gone was zero.
It can't be E.
It has to M-O or R.
Let's see.
vote higher hope pray was zero yeah exactly so yes uh uh oh
god was one oh so it should be like oh and e oh no then it
should be if it's one then it should be it can't be e
Fork!
There's a fork!
Where's fork?
I got locked out.
You guys fucked with me.
Guys, it's okay.
It's okay.
I have Radaway.
Guys, I have Radaway.
We could do it again, guys.
I have Radaway, guys.
It's okay.
It might not look really good right now, but I have Radaway.
Alright.
Made.
Zero.
How about...
Okay, it's not any of that, so it's not M.
How about life?
It's zero.
Okay, this is bad.
How about poor?
Okay, it's also zero.
Okay, let me reset it.
I figured it out.
All right, very, all right, title.
Okay, gold.
Okay, I'm going to reset it.
Kape.
Likeness is one.
So it's our CAP gain.
Okay, it's A.
Then it has to be A then.
uh warm it's a obviously lake is it lake what the fuck is it
why am I so bad at this oh why is this such me smashed It's
Okay No Fuck
Guys I I can't accidentally use my stim pack Okay Here we go
This is it Draw Likeness 1 Is it dark?
Zero So it's not D So it's either R A or W R A or W Okay R A
or W Where the fuck is R-A or W?
R-R-A-F-Fear!
Fear!
Okay, it's A!
Alright, it's A.
It's...
It's the A.
It has to be the A.
Where else would it be?
But like, what else can it be, though?
What?
It's a way?
Where's the way?
It's not a way.
it's not a way guys guys we have to crack this
guys what can it be yard zero wave zero all right we give
okay reset all right from roll pure are you serious none of
them okay door warm Help!
I swear to God, I have to, there's no evil!
Feel, oh, oh, oh, oh, two, two, two.
Okay, we got it.
Two.
Okay, two.
Okay, it has to be...
Okay, is there another one that has double E's?
Is there another one?
Seek!
We're Seek!
Where is it?
How do you see?
Yes!
We did it.
I fucking knew.
This will be my first and only entry.
I identify myself.
But I can't believe I did all that for lore.
I identify myself as a free-thinking individual of these
once great United States.
I will not stand idly by as the government infects the minds
of its people with devices like the electrical tower.
They've erected in my front lawn.
I pledge to take down this mind-controlled device by any
means necessary and also begun construction on an...
uh on a device if you're reading this i've certainly been
killed or detained in the government interrogation camp the
news will surely wrap the truth and ban ran me as a traitor
do not believe their lies let's all true patriots know that
what i do i do of my own free will and for the for the good
of my country that that's it that was it i lost half my hp
that was it i fuck you gray whatever rain grotsky fuck you I
did all of that.
Okay, where's my rat away?
Where is the fucking five cheese?
Is it help?
Is it helping?
I can't tell.
Is it?
Did it help?
Oh my god, it's going down!
Rad X.
Rad resist.
Oh, it resists rad.
Okay.
Rad resist.
That just resists I should have been taking RadX this entire
time
Bob, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you You
see lines closed with brackets Like clicking them will
remove a wrong answer Couldn't be a life set Oh my god, I
could have Guys, what the fuck?
Where was my backseat earlier?
Thank you for the super chat, Bob Thank you, thank you I'm
slowly learning Guys, I'm just role playing as two intellect
guys.
I know what I'm doing.
I just want to be more immersive
I'm just trying to be more immersive chat Zonerman thank you
for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fake Canadian doesn't even know the name it's referencing.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't I don't I'm sorry.
I don't watch hockey
one of the two Canadians that don't watch hockey the only
hockey team I know is the Canucks that's the only hockey
hockey and then what happened after like was it after the
Stanley Cup all right where am I uh okay I cleared it wait I
want to head to Diamond City can I just run the Diamond City
okay talk to the sellers where the fuck is Diamond City
Where is it?
I thought they marked Diamond City for me.
I thought they marked...
Oh, there it is!
Place marker.
It's time.
We're straight to Diamond City.
Where's the marker?
Is it this way?
Alright, it's time.
It's time.
Our journey is to Diamond City.
Let's go.
run time we just go straight to diamond city whoa to diamond
city we go oh ow i don't understand why are they shooting me
we had a deal trudy wait i'm poison i ain't giving you
poison shilling chem pushers anything who's that he bought
them fair and square trudy hello what's going on over I'm
heading to Diamond City.
Hello.
What, huh?
Lower your gun.
I have two charisma.
Or it's gonna involve me.
That's it.
What?
Bro, what?
I don't...
Guys, did I have to do this again?
No, I don't.
No, thank God.
Okay.
The diamond city we go.
What happened to me?
Holy shit.
Not so fast.
I'm gonna fucking heal.
Oh my god.
What the fuck happened?
Who killed?
I'm gonna fucking, I'm shooting them first.
I can't believe it, my two charisma failed me.
I fucking learned my lesson.
Where are they?
They can't just shoot me.
What?
How did he survive that?
Holy shit.
Oh, he doesn't die by a headshot.
doesn't die from a headshot it's okay it's okay it's okay
boom there we go okay this gun fucking sucks i'm fucking
swapping guns
is this better oh never mind cogsworth did everything nice i
did it wait he has a insane gun i'm taking that gun what was
that gun what was that gun that i just took was it the
action okay revolve damage 24 oh my god i could have looked
at the damage damage 45 oh 28 that's insane dragonbuster
wait dragonbuster okay i'm gonna this one's easier it has
more ammo sorry guys i can't wait hey guys
I'm sorry.
I can rest easy knowing that Wolfgang is rotten in hell.
Thank you.
I literally saved your life.
Uh...
Barter.
I got a few minutes to browse.
A little bit of everything.
Oh, wait.
Is this to buy?
No, I don't need your shit.
I saved your life!
You gonna buy?
Okay.
Yeah, are you okay?
It's gonna take my son a while to get off the chems, but
we'll make it.
Varsen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ultimate power boots.
Show up, say stop, then die.
Just browsing for now.
Did she pay me?
Oh, she did?
I didn't notice.
Wait, if I kill her, can I just steal everything?
I'm just saying.
Not worth it.
fine okay not barter i've got a few minutes to browse i lose
the store forever but what would i buy from the store what
would i need from them like oh general chow's revenge what
does 50 more damage holy he has so much stuff what do i sell
i don't know what's like worthless i can't tell everything
seems like super useful to me you can sell your just sell
your stuff But what would I sell?
Everything seems like something I want to keep.
I guess I don't need two gas masks.
I don't need two gas masks.
What else do I not need?
Gas mask with goggles.
I guess I don't need two of these.
I'll just take like one of them.
And then sell the...
Oh yeah, the wedding ring.
I should sell my wedding ring to let people know I'm not
married anymore.
watching 16 bottle caps my husband cheaped out on the
wedding ring it's not even made a real diamond
i can't believe it he cheaped out on her love that's fucked
up that's so fucked up he doesn't love he doesn't he never
loved me
oh shit 78 not even a hundred it's not even a hundred
um toy car wait where's the toy car t um but what if i need
the toy car later what if i need this all right i'll just
click a Accept.
Confirm trade.
I'll take that.
Alright, let's go.
I can't believe I can't...
I did all that for nothing.
Okay.
I'm sorry, Cogsworth, for stealing that one item.
I didn't know what I was doing.
I'm sorry.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go, Cogsworth!
We're gonna go to Diamond City!
We're not ending stream until we get to Diamond City!
oh i got carrot flower diamond city here we come
yay should have been 500.
okay how cooked on a scale one to ten is our oh she's
reading look i'm just trying to role play as i'm just role
playing as the two intellect person it's all rp it's not
real it's not thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you okay this way wait what the What?
Did I went the wrong way?
I'm going the wrong way.
But what's in front of me?
It's roleplay.
It's two now.
I learned how to read.
Guys, it's two now.
I read one book and I got...
I increased my intellect.
It might have been a picture book, but it was a book
nonetheless.
Whoa.
What's that sound?
Do you guys hear that?
all right let's see we gotta go this way we gotta head to
diamond city wait i'm going further away from diamond city
what the no i'm freaking tricked myself to go to the
settlement this is my marker i almost i almost tricked
myself into going to the settlement
yeah exactly they're doubled my intelligence guys I doubled
it.
Does anyone live here?
Mystic Pines?
Who lives here?
Hello?
Oh, I could take it.
People are dead.
Okay.
Nice.
That's what I...
What's that sound?
That's what I like to hear.
What is that sound?
You guys hear that?
I'm gonna steal some stuff though first What is that?
Who's outside?
Hello?
Okay, we're gonna We're gonna We're gonna make sure we don't
die Hello?
I heard like boom Boom boom
What's that?
I heard I heard the sound The boom Oh Oh, that's so sad.
I'm going to take it.
The dead don't talk, guys.
The dead don't talk.
It's fine.
Okay, so there's no bridge.
And...
Oh, it's this way.
Okay.
I think it'll be fine when we go this way.
It'll be fine.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I have meds to take.
I can get through this.
I can also walk around Because it's this way It's so Diamond
City Here I come Just a small town girl Trying to make it in
the big wide world Big wide radiated world Who's it?
Ooh, flower I don't know what it does But I want it Alright,
here we go Yeah, I'm on hard mode right now guys that's why
death clock took me 80 years is there any items i can steal
from here there's a box here what's this for hogsburg is
actually so fucking strong i never expected it all right
nice let blood men suffer five and easier to persuade and
dialogue oh my god wait
The ginger plant is working!
This is it.
I can finally persuade the men.
Is it?
I can finally Riz.
This is it!
Holy fuck.
There we go.
Oh no, not the plus one radiation.
The Riz.
We're back!
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, I thought that was like a little duck on my screen.
Wait, where's the...
Where's my checkpoint?
Oh, there it is.
How do I...
How do I still get lost?
Wait, is there any items here?
Hello?
Oh, Nuka Cola!
Nuka Cola!
Memo, inventory checklist.
Radiation King.
Who the fuck is the radiation king?
Just reminding you about the inventory coming in tonight, we
talked about, like I said, this should remain off the books
and kept between as few dock workers as possible.
The units are heavy and will require the forklift.
Wait.
Power is behind me?
Where's the power armor?
There is?
Where is it?
Hello?
What a power armor at.
Back to the barricades?
Like back here?
Power armor here?
Oh there it is!
Guys.
Cosworth!
Can you hack your robot?
Unlock this!
Please.
I can't hack it.
I'm too dumb.
I'm too stupid.
I don't understand.
I was doing so well with my hacking.
How could this be?
He actually can?
Coxworth!
This is why I got you overdog me.
it cause her get over here all right let's go cogsworth get
over here get over here cogsworth this is exactly what got
you hey here you go no way okay talk yes relationship can i
fuck a robot your thoughts a neutron walks into a bar and
asks gender response for you no charge
All right.
Relationship.
How do you feel about us?
What?
I bought you!
I programmed you!
That's all.
Wait, how do I make him...
And then E on the console?
Follow.
Go check that out.
Wait, let me...
Not possible.
What's your worth?
What?
It's not even possible, guys.
He said it's not possible.
He's too stupid.
I can't believe it.
He's also too stupid.
Take him out on the tape first.
Wait, what is electronics?
Oh, no, not...
No!
I tricked myself into getting into a loading screen.
What's this place?
Where am I?
What is this place, Cogsworth?
Are there people here?
Wait, what?
Oh, I don't feel safe.
Oh, I don't...
I don't feel safe.
I don't know.
I don't know about...
There's too many electronics out here.
Oh, I don't feel safe.
What if they activate?
Oh, I'm going to steal some money, though.
Let's see.
I'm going to steal some stuff, though.
Oh, be fun.
They're deactivated right now.
They deactivate.
I can steal some stuff.
Please assume the position.
Yeah, I don't feel very safe that...
Whoa!
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Okay, nice.
Oh, shit.
I do not have the ammo for this.
I just realized I definitely don't have the ammo for this
gun.
So we'll just use the typical 10mm pistol for now.
Alright.
So I'm just gonna leave.
I'm just gonna leave.
They seem like the type of robots that won't stay
deactivated.
We have a main goal here.
They look like they can turn on at any second.
They do.
I must take every junk.
I see item I take.
I am a loot goblin.
War never changes.
Especially my looting habits.
Oh my god.
This loading screen.
You wouldn't think that like after six plus years the
loading screen would just be a little bit faster
Please it didn't crash it's moving I'm literally looking at
it move Nine I said plus guys I made sure to say plus years
Please.
No, don't say it crashed.
Don't say I haven't made it to Diamond City yet.
I haven't made it.
Yeah.
Why is it taking so long?
No, it's moving.
It's moving.
I see the screen moving.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it never crashed.
I've always been.
in you Todd Todd don't listen to them holy shit why is it so
far Todd I always believe in you and Todd we trust it just
works this is you guys never believed in him that's why your
game keeps crashing I should I should save I should save all
right this way we don't end stream until I'm making the
diamond city.
This is all I want.
Somebody's fighting, but we're gonna ignore him.
Whoa, what is that?
What the fuck is that?
That's a cow.
Wait, can I loot the cow?
Oh my god.
Wait, where's the door to this?
Wait, I want to loot the cow.
Okay.
Can I loot you?
Please, can I...
Can you come to me?
No, why can't I loot the cow?
If you kill it?
Can I...
Should I kill it?
He doesn't have an owner.
His owner's dead.
Oh, I can.
Go, Cogsworth!
Oh my god.
Nice.
I looted him.
Get him!
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Whoa, what the fuck?
Why are people fighting?
I don't understand.
What?
Not me.
Look, I only have one mission here.
I don't need you guys.
Yay!
We got beef!
Guys, we're eating good tonight!
Dragoons!
Mama's got some beef!
Alright, we're all gonna...
Okay.
All of you guys got to share one beef though, okay?
Is that okay?
Are these good people?
Hey, guys.
Ah!
Guys, that's not a good place.
He's back on the menu, boys.
Guys, apparently they were not good people.
talk to her but she did not want to talk to me for some
reason all right so we're gonna figure out oh wait i can
just walk past this bridge yes it's a little bit radiant
water see no no all right it's fine we're fine drinking
unpurified what causes radiation damage well good thing i'm
pure oh yeah where's the oh it's this way all right trinity
tire signal found 10 bananas exactly I just ate like 10
fucking bananas where's Cogsworth I'll come back right he'll
be back guys I just want to go to Diamond City we're on a
pathway to Diamond City let's go whoa there's so many empty
cities though yeah a little vegetation never hurts like if a
tumor grows or something it's just benign it's like a second
head with that cow that cow is okay with a second head so
i'll be okay wait can i rob this guy i hear something you
let me see coxford's okay oh shit okay
no okay it's okay and i have a lot
okay oh no is it here yeah oh shit you see that fucking
rifle i'm gonna take these coffee cups too and a cigarette
wait what oh it's just modding my no we don't need a mod
anything we don't need a mod anything i'm perfect wait is he
alive hey there oh you're a diamond city That's where I'm
trying to go to.
It's okay.
He didn't see me rob him.
Yeah!
Keep moving, Scatter.
Excuse me.
Move along.
Here, the different raider groups are carving up conch like
a Christmas turkey.
He's a Diamond City security guard.
This is one of their bases?
Oh!
Wait, I'm so close.
Diamond City!
Hey there.
Wait, does that mean if I can bring in like a horde of
monsters and then they'll shoot, kill them for me?
Oh my god!
We're, we're almost there!
Oh my god, there's like turrets and everything.
We're almost there, we're almost at the homeland!
We're almost at Diamond City!
I mean, you can't open the gate.
Hello, who are you?
Danny, I'm standing out in the ocean.
open here for crying out loud i got orders not to let you in
miss piper i'm sorry i'm just doing my job oh just doing
your job i like i'm right in the back of there is that it oh
look it's the scary reporter i'm sorry but mayor mcdonough's
really steamed piper saying that article you wrote was all
lies the whole city's in a tizzy what's going on
Can I kill her accidentally?
Shoot her in the leg?
Hello, Piper!
You want into Diamond City, right?
Yeah, I want into Diamond City.
Who are you?
What?
What, what's that?
You said you're a trader up from Quincy?
You have enough supplies to keep the general store stocked
for a whole month?
Yeah, it's me!
you hear that danny you're gonna open the gate and let us in
are you gonna be the one talking to crazy merna about losing
out on all the supply yeah cause we're has so many supplies
give me a minute well i did it better headings right quick
before danny catches all my blood i mean i technically i can
open my own store honestly with all the stuff i have i got
the diamond city Do I talk to the mayor?
Who let you back inside?
I told Sullivan to keep that gate shut.
You devious, rabble-rousing, slanderer.
The level of dishonesty in that paper of yours.
I'll have that printer scrapped for parts.
Ooh, that a statement, Mr. McDenna?
Tyrant mayor shuts down the press.
ship you support the news because the mayor's threatened to
throw free speech in the dumpster one newspaper what
newspaper are you talking about i would never censor my
dragoons because my dragoons are gonna be like oh i love
jokey she's so smart and she knows what she's doing and
she's like the best gamer out there right dragoons i'll
never censor you guys because i know you're gonna always say
positive things about me lies who said that who said that
give me a sec give me a sec guys
who else who else wants to say anything
lies oh who said that who said that let me put you in a
little time out anyway i'll never censor my dragoons i would
never support i hate newspapers just like to stir up trouble
this message hasn't corrected my showkeeper
oh i didn't mean to bring you into this argument miss don't
keep that let me rewrite this real quick welcome to the
great green jewel of the common well thank you super chat
loves don't keep good oh my god i know don't he's amazing
thank you love thank you super chat uh you two arguing what
are you two arguing about anyway
Thank you.
Lies?
There's no lies here.
Jagoon Media Headline.
Smart brain.
20 intellect.
All charisma.
Oh, she.
Oh, my gosh.
I know.
Thank you for the gentle soup, but thank you.
Thank you.
Missing person.
I'm trying to find someone.
Trying to find someone?
Who?
Uh, my baby.
A boy.
An infant boy.
Kidnapped.
Did you say kidnapped?
Mike Doki is the best guy to see my family.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
I'm afraid that our security team can't follow every case
that comes through.
I'm confident that you can find help here.
Diamond City has every conceivable service known to man.
One of our great citizens can surely find the title.
They know where my boy is?
Oh my God, he's a man.
I have better persuasion.
A mayor of a great city.
must know everyone who can help me oh i'm sorry i don't know
no it's because it's because he doesn't like women you can
tell you can tell that he's like he's gay diamond city six
settled in but um it's not zero risk i'm not his preference
you can tell he's not into women that's why
You tell he's not into women!
Why else would my persuasion not work?
Die!
Censored and cancelled.
Get on inside.
Yay.
How is that castle book?
He's not straight.
Why else would he say no?
Guys.
Look at me!
I'm...
Wasteland woman
Whoa Look at the diamond city It's a fucking shithole
Why else would my Persuasion not work?
I don't understand The stream was down for it If he has Are
you trying to say I give zero standards He said he's gay
like seven times i didn't think it was a super chat thank
you thank you
well the presses are getting overloaded that motor is going
to go soon if we don't replace it now you've been saying
that for weeks and the old girl still keeps cranking stop
worrying so much now i gotta head into the i said he's
getting it tied he's coming our way why is something wrong
The streamer is so bad, it came the streamer's broke.
Thank you for the Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
All right, I think this is a good time to call it here,
guys.
We made it to Diamond City!
Oh my god, we did it.
We did it.
Our self-imposed mission.
Yeah, I'm taking with the Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Looks like someone leaves and there are more charisma.
Thank you for the Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
you has been so on so far though and can't wait to do more
oh my gosh we're already sidetracked this is not gonna go so
well we're we're already so sidetracked with everything
so i have a feeling it's not uh it's not gonna go well uh of
course part two is that is happening it's in my it's in my
stream schedule it's in my edge so yeah i can't wait to do
another part two it's been so fun so far uh i'm already like
super sidetracked so there's there's like definitely a lot
of stuff i don't even know where the main storyline is to be
fair i have no idea where the main storyline is at the
moment so this is gonna be uh this is gonna be a little
rough i have no idea how many parts we're gonna do follow
had a great time everybody had a great time um i would love
to do like a little zatz on in the end but i'm very very
busy today so uh we did talk a little bit before we started
today so um we did have a little chatting stream before we
started but anyway guys i had a great time with all of you i
hope you guys had a great time watching me and as always
everybody stay hydrated posture get up and move around to
get that blood flowing and if you stay up from me head to
bed because you deserve Bye guys Bye